Так.
안녕하십턴 여러분 행복한 투자정을
함께하는 체슬리 모닝 브리프 6월
24일 수요일 1부 시작하겠습니다.
예 먼저 전일 중국 시작 왕경부장님
함께 보겠습니다.네
>> 어제는 아시아 증시 돈반 좀
빠졌고요. 그래서 지수도 거의
1.4% 정도 빠졌습니다. 흥승태
지수는 마이너스 3.3% 하라하고
정시 과대는 3.5조는 수준을
유지했어요. 업종별 좀 푸시면 어제는
금융 헬스케어 유틸리티 업종이 가선대
강세 배웠고 반면은 소재케이션 IT
업종이 약세 배웠습니다. 겁에던 그
저가 매수 자금 위으로 금융주 어세가
좀 반등 나오고요. 농업는 2.7%
올라고 공산는 2.5% 무증 저축는
2.9% 올라왔어요. 정시 거래대금
회복 그리고 대용 FPO 등기 때문에
정권주어세도 올라왔어요. 종신 강투는
5% 건발전관는 2.7%
올라왔습니다. 어 광산매 가격 상승등
기대금으로 광선매 관련주 그냥 강세를
보였습니다. 어제는 우리 얘기하는 거
전비 광선이잖아요. 그냥 뭐 예외
없이 10% 정도 상한가
기록했습니다. 어 정체 테크는
3.5% 올라왔습니다. 반도세 캐패스
화대 등 기대으로 반도세 정비주
어세도 상승세가 지수되었어요. 부방
화천는 염증 3% 승미상하에는 요증
3% 어 장천테크네요.이 회사는음
호공증 장비 회사입니다. 어제는 4%
올라고 화풍 테스트는 또 거의 4%
올라왔어요.이 이런 회상 다수 역사는
신고냈어요.
PCB 업체 대규모 정찰 등인걸로
관영 장비도 강세였습니다. 대조
레이저는 10% 정도 상한가
기록했습니다. 대조 속동을 2정 6%
오라하고 유령주 어제도 반등
나왔습니다. 어 환능 수전는 염증
1% 환능 구변을 염증 8%
올라왔어요. 한편에 요리선물 공고
부조에 따라서 관련주들이 그냥 강세를
요지하고 있고요. 중국 거는 어제는
여었습니다.
중국 거서 어제는 임중 9%로 여서
신거신됐냈습니다. 어 반면은 소재
PCB 광통신 관영주 어제는 다
빠졌어요. 신념물 구체 금리 어제
염증이 선성했습니다. 이념물 구체
금리는 일정 이P 선승하고 외한화
환율는 염정이 24% 전라되었습니다.
어저께 어 한국 [목을 가다듬음]
시장이 물론 이제 레버리지 영향,
ETF 영향이라고는 하는데 가장 많이
아시아 시장 중에서 많이 좋았고
그래도 일본도 한 3% 정도 하락을
했는데 중국도 아시아 시장에서 이제
업종별 그 동조환은 있다고 가정하면
>> 네
>> 아무리 반도체 장비 주더라도 좀
빡락했어야 되는 거 아닌가 하는 생각
드는데
>> 그런 개별 재료가 있었습니다. 그
>> 뭐 태별한 거는 없습니다. 그냥
최근에 많이 올라가는 건 샤시험 매물
때문에 좀 빠졌고요. IT
세터식적으로 보시면 IT는 지금 미정
8.7%밖에 7%밖에 없어요.
>> 어떤 지수에서
>> 그 IT 그 여기에서 CS 300
업종별 좀 보시면
>> CSI 한 지에서
>> 맞아요. IT 차비 8 7% 바에
없어요. 그래서이 부분을 세게
하셔서도 정년 시전을 거의 뭐 영향지
못할 수 가능성이 있어요.
회사들 그니까 미국 중심의
[목을 가다듬음]
글로벌 투자 전략 자료들을 보면
아시아 시장에서 이제 상해 지수를 어
아웃포폼으로 놓는 이유 중에 하나가
어 중국이 어떤 자체 선택를 갖기
때문에 경쟁력 있는
>> 기업들 위주로 이제 경쟁력 있는 시총
상위 기업들 위주로 구성되어 있는
상해 종합 아 CSI 300 같은
것들은 상당히 그 유망하다라는
>> 어
>> 당연한 어쩌면
>> 그 당연한 이유와 게 어 전 세계
주요 시장과 상관계수가 0에 가깝다.
>> 그래서 전 세계 주요 시장이 혹시 안
좋아지게 되면
>> 어 중국 시장이 투자한 것이 어느
정도 해치 역할을 할 것이다라고
얘기를 하고 있는데 그런 부분들이
어저께 좀 보여진 건가 싶기도
했습니다.
>> 네. 네. 맞습니다. 네. 오늘
가져오는 관영 호산도 하나 있어요.
>> 음.이 이 호전은 그냥 이번 달 초
그대는 또 한번 소개했습니다. 거리
가정이잖네요.
회산 [콧방귀] 지금 시가주에
47조원 정도 되고요. 뭐 지난 이번
달 초 그때 비 또 설자
내려갔습니다. 지금 포드 P는 일곱배
되고 포드 PBR 1등 300
수준이고요. 뭐 중국 에어컨콩 시장은
뭐 1등 유지하고 있고 중국 내수는
74% 수출 12% 정도 되습니다.
뭐 1번기 실전은 저한테 나오고요.
동의비 3.5% 5% 증가. 수익는
동의 3% 증가했습니다. GP 마지는
그냥 플라이 수준을 유지하고 MP
마지포 하라 했습니다. 별 문제가
없고요. 뭐 1번기 기준으로는
거래전는 에어컨 1.5% 증가하고
시장 1등 유지하고 있습니다.음이
회사는 어 끝제 그 공시 하나
나왔어요. 회사는 야 5.3% 위한
정도 그 임직관 대성으로 주시 보유
계획를 받했어요.
>> 주시 보유
>> 계획
>> 네. ESOP입니다.
>> 맞아요.
>> 뭐 승과 조는 좀 여러 가지 좀
있는데요. 핵심 보면 좀 보시면
원래부터 내년 아 18% 이상 플러스
현금 배당 성형 50% 이상승시
100% 규수 하위는 12% 이상
18% 이하 플러스 배당 조건 총시
80% 그렇게 얘기했어요. 어 이거
달성하면은 그 직원한테 임직관한테 그
주식 주는 거예요. 근데이 주는 거는
임중 사는 거 아니고 그냥 회사 동력
그 사후 임지 주는 거예요. 얘는
인센티브 방식으로 하했어요. 이번 달
초가 회산을 주조주 혼화 증도 하면
밥했어요. 어 거의 배당 성향
57.8% 8%하고 나오고 어 정체는
70% 이상 다 소각 이런 거 다
제시했습니다. 6월 17일 기준으로는
원래는이 회사 예상 PBR는
1.4배로 역성 취조 수준까지
내려갔어요.
2022년부터 2024년 그때는 또
거의 1승 400배 정도까지
내려갔어요. 그 이유가 그때 실조에
대한 우려감이 있어요. 왜냐면 원자들
가격 상승 때문에 실전은 좀 뭐
거증도 있어요. 최근에 빠티는 거는
실수가 아니고 반도체 술린상은 너무
심하니까
이런 회자를 수가 되었어요. 그래서
주가 계속 내려갔어요.
이외는 원래는이 회사 예상 주인률을
약 10% 정도 초과했어요. 1번개
마켓 소승는 1773만 정도 가지고
있어요. 그래서 완화를 뭐 환승하면은
40조원 정도 되고요. 뭐 시가 중에
정체 차지 비중 85% 정도 되고
순연금 제외하면은이 홀사 지금 피는
그냥 1 정도 됩니다. 네. 왜냐면
7조밖에 없어요. 현금 빼면 네. 막
현금 빼고 그래서이 권대 정관 리퍼들
보면은 저가 저평가 그리고 거 배당
등 건조물로 매수 의견을 유지했어요.
정부 가정 구매 그 보조금제 축소에
다음에 원래 내년 내 홍양순 있는 각
290억 300억 320억 외로
출정되었고 지정 대비 그냥 4% 소포
화용 조준했어요. 타케로 원래는 열배
피규해서 TP는 54위 정도는
유지했어요. 어제 종가 대비는 45%
없애 나올 수 있어요.음
>> 감사합니다. 네. 자만 하나 더
쭤볼게요. 거리 가전 맨 위엔 줄에
시가 총액 47조원은
>> 이게 코리안 원
>> 맞아요. 다 환산했어.
>> 환산해서
>> 밑에 그런데 이제 수년금이 1773억
위안이니까네
>> 이거를 어 원화로 환산하면 막 40조
안파 30조 넘어가
>> 30조
>> 그러니까 어 이제 그렇게 계산해서
수연금 다 빼면
>> 실제로 이익 나오는 것 대비 시가
총액은 뭐 한 P 1배 수준밖에 안
되 엄청나게 싸다
>> 그렇게 말씀 주신 거 같아요맞네
>> 어 이거를 이제 시장이 인지하지
못하고 있는 투자 기회라고 봐요 지
이럴 만한 이유가 있어서
>> 시가 총액 47조원이나 되는데
>> 어 주가가 오르지 못하고 있는 건지
우리 왕부장은 어느 쪽에 부괴가 더
있습니까? 저 개인적으로 생각는 이거
실적에 대한 걱정이 없고 약간 뭐가
요즘에 그 요동성 면제가도 있잖아요.
이거 자금들이 다 반도체 제조로
가니까 혹시나 이거는 순화 되면은
이런 회사는 아마 좀 반등할 가능성도
있다고 생각하고 있고요. 왜냐면이
회사는 계속 그 주중 증이가 강화하고
있어요.이 가치 투자자 관점부로
하면은 되게 우량주입니다. 되게 우량
줄로 생각할 수 있어요.
>> 그래서이 약간 좀 뭐 소외되는
회사입니다. 네. 그런 느낌.
>> 네. 회사가 계속해서 시가총 아,
현금으로 된 때 시가 총액만큼
>> 혹은 그 이상 어쩌면
>> 영업 현금 흐름을 내고 있는
회사이다라는 생각이 좀 들어서
맞아요.
>> 그것들을 충분히 주주들에게 돌려
주겠다는 어떤 약속이 일시적인게
아니라 그냥 쭉
>> 네.
>> 상당히 긴 기간이라는
>> 보장이나 믿음이 생기면
>> 네. 주가는 어느 정도 한번 레벨업이
된 상태에서 또 업항에 따라서 등락을
보일 수도 있겠다. 그런 생각을 좀
해 봅니다. 네.
>> 어, 중국 주식 왕부장님이 추천해
주실 때 뭐 이렇게 가치주 성향의
종목들은 좀 많지 않은데
>> 네.
>> 어, 좀 있습니다.
>> 아, 네.
>> 중국에서도 이런 기업이 있다. 이런
기업 잘 찾으면 또 하나의 스타일이
나올 수 있을 것 같아요. 이런
기업들만 또 그득그득 이렇게 갖고
있다 보면은네. 어 성장주나 뭐 AI
관련한 어떤 그 테마가 확 이제
역방향으로 움직였을 때 급 주목을
받을 수도 있는 그런 스타일이라고
생각이 돼서 좋은 종목으로
>> 관심 종목에 좀 넣어 두고
보겠습니다.
>> 네.
>> 감사합니다. 중국 시장 여기까지
보고요. 미국 시장으로 넘어가야 될
텐데. 어, 미국 시장 저는 그냥
헤드라인만 좀 봤거든요. 유리프로
그냥 어, 한국이 미국 시장에 선물
같았다. 뭐 그런 느낌 좀 있습니다.
자세한 내용을 우리 리프로에게
들어보도록 하겠습니다.
>> 네. 어, 말씀 주신 것처럼 좀 어,
선물이었지만 그 진짜 선물은 아니
정말 험악하게 마감된 어제
하루였는데요. 이제 주요 지수들 먼저
보시면은 필반 지수랑 나스닥 SMP
500 러셀 2,000 뭐 다우으로
하락을 다 했습니다. 하락 폭이 이제
뭐 일반 지수부터 가장 컸고요. 어제
밤에 제가 한 11시 반쯤에 좀 해
가지고 계속 트래킹을 하면서 다우가
소폭 상승하는 거 확인하고 잠을
자는데 오늘 장 마감 직전에도 좀
깨서 잠깐 팠거든요. 한 4시 반
잠깐 상승했던 구간이 한 번 더 튀긴
있었더라고요. 다 기준으로.
>> 네. 다어 기준으로 그래서 결국에는요
다어 기준으로 봤을 때 좀 막판에
결국 이제 하락하면서 마감하긴 했는데
막판에 좀 매물 나오면서 약보합으로
좀 마감을 했습니다. 그래서 저는 좀
다우를 긍정적으로 봤던게 장중에 이제
두 번이나 플러스로 올라왔다는 데에서
오늘 좀 장세를 완전 이제이 좀
허막했다라고만 이제 요약하기보다는 좀
장세 힌트가 있을 것 같아서 말씀을
드렸는데 주요 지수들이 좀 크게
하락하고 뭐 다시 이것저것 버터에서
뭐 버블이라는 단어가 계속 등장하긴
하더라고요. 그래도 이제 다오의 장중
플러스 전환이 두 번 있었다는 점만
보면은 또 완전히 투매장이라기보다는
또 방어는 있었지만 막판까지는 확신은
좀 없었던 장이었다라고 볼 수 있을
것 같습니다. 그래서 결국 좀 막판에
마우도 밀렸다는 점에서 찝찝하면
여전히 좀 남아 있긴 한데 나스이랑
필반 약세가 뭐 시장 전체 약세처럼
좀 보이게 더 강조한 장이었고 그래서
뭐 다컴 법을 말기 본보다는 그가
너무 이제 AI랑 반도체 쪽에 올랐기
때문에 좀 쏠림을 완화한 차익실현
성격이 보다 이제 강한 장이었다라고
말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같습니다. 이제
우측의 섹터 쪽도 그래서 보시면 다
내린 장은 아니었고요. 방어 섹터는
좀 상승을 했습니다. 하단에 이제
코멘트로도 잠깐 기재를 드렸는데
헬스케어나 금융 필수 소비제 뭐
에너지 부동산 유틸리티 색 섹터는
이제 상승을 했습니다.이 중에서도
이제 필수 소비자랑 헬스 기어
부동산은 1% 넘게 상승을 했고요.
또 반대쪽에 반대로 이제 정보 기술
IT 섹터 쪽은 3% 정도 하락하면서
지수 전체를 좀 끌어내렸습니다.
여기서 이제 말씀 주셨듯이 코스피
언급을 안 할 수가 없는데 이제 왼쪽
하단에 이동하셔서 보시면 반도체 쪽
보시면 모두 약세였습니다. 특히 이제
마이크론과 샌디스크 이제 각각 디램
뭐 HBM 그리고 랜드하는 메모리
주들인데 두 자릿수 하락을 했습니다.
사실 이제 첫 동인은 미국장에서 먼저
터졌다기보다는 어제 뭐 국장에서
코스피가 한 9.9% 9% 하락을
했고 이제 아무래도 시총 50% 이상
차지하는 3전이랑 닉스가 각각 이제
하락 급락을 하면서요 급락의 흐름이
미국의 메모리랑 반도체 장비주로 좀
전염됐다라고 좀 볼 수 있을 것
같습니다. 그 이제 추가적으로 좀
이런 보도들이 계속 불 그 베어리
시작이 나오면서 어제 블룸버그
테크에서도 인터뷰를 몇 군데 한게
있었는데 이제 닐 캠플링이란
애널리스트가 하이닉스랑 나스닥 약세를
좀 연결해서 코멘트를 했더라고요.
그래서이 애널리스트 이제 코멘트
핵심은 뭐 메모리 업항의 질에 대한
의심이었는데 뭐 일부 보도랑 시장
코멘트에서는 뭐 SK 하이닉스가
HPM 대량 생산 확대 속도를 좀
조절을 하고 최근 가격이 오 크게
오를 이제 법륜 디램 쪽으로 케파를
전환화를 한다라는 그냥 언오피셜한
보도가 나왔습니다. 그래서 확인이 좀
필요하긴 할 텐데 일단 이런 말이
나왔다는 것만으로도 법령 디램 쪽으로
뭐 생산과 수익성 논의가 나온다는요
그냥 보더 하나만으로도 시장
입장에서는 뭐 HPM 가격이나 HI
뭐 AI 메모리 모멘텀이 생각보다
강하지 않은 거 아니냐라 아니면 이제
뭐 AI 보도가 해당 보도가 이제 뭐
AI별 수익성에 대한 실사를 좀 탄광
속에 카나리아처럼 보고 있다 하는
이제 표현을 쓰고 있더라고요. 그래서
그런 HBM에 대한 수익성에 대한
질문을 던졌고 근데 이제 오히려
공식적으로 뭐 보도된 바에 따르면은
데이터에 근거를 해야 되니까 H 그
하이닉스 같은 경우는 최근에 뭐
차세대 HPM 그 4위 샘플을 주요
고객사에 추화하면서 AI 메모리
대응을 계속 하고 있기 때문에 뭐
이런 우려성 코멘트는 실제 수요가
수요 두가 뭐 확인됐다라기보다는
시장이 좀 생산 믹스랑 수익성 변화
가능성을 먼저 의심하면서 반응한
것으로 보는게 더 적절할 것
같습니다. 그리도 추가적으로요이
애널리스트가 테크 세트로 오래 보기는
했는데요. 좀 찾아보니까 기술주
네티브에는 좀 회의적인 발언을 계속
해왔기 때문에요 점도 좀 참고하실
필요 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 프한테 신상 털렸네. [웃음]
네.
>> 네.이어서
이어서 좀 유가도 그래서 함께 점검을
해 볼 필요가 있을 것 같은데 뭐
아래쪽에 항상 가져 그니까 어태치하는
이제 그 크로드 오일 그 WTI 쪽에
보시면은 WTI 일중 차트도 가져왔고
또 계속 하락 추세고요. 그리고 또
브랜드 같은 경우에도 텍스트로 항상
달아들이고 있는데 둘 다 이제
내렸습니다. 그리고 또 계속 하락하고
있는 추세이기도 하고요. 그
기름값이라고 제가 이제 통칭해서
말씀을 드리고 있는데 요게 이제
WTI 중심으로 말씀을 드리고
있거든요. 이게 도대체 뭔 차이냐라고
좀 궁금해하실 수도 있을 것 같아서
한번 다시 짚어 드리면 시장 지표
기준으로 보면 WTI는 지금 미국
본토에서 생산이 되기 때문에 미국
내수 시장의 기름값을 좀 결정하는
지표고 그래서 이게 미국 내 에너지
가격하고 가솔린 가격 볼 때 좀
중요한 참고 지표라서 물론 WTI가
내려간다라고 해서 가솔린이 같이
하락한다라는 거는 아니기는 한데 결국
이게 미국 내에서 가솔린 소비가 많기
때문에 인플레이션 압력이 좀 완화되면
뭐 연준이 금리를 덜 올리거나
나중에는 뭐 가솔린이나 WTI 때문에
이하나 여지도 생길 수 있다 정도의
시나리오를 연결할 수 있어서 뭐
기름값이 내리면은 뭐 인플레이션
그리고 금리까지 연결해서 계속
말씀드리고 있기 때문에요 브랜드유랑
그리고요 WTA가 동반 하락했다는
점이 좀 추세적으로 인플레이션 압력이
줄어드는 것으로 봐도 되지 않을까
정도로 저는 볼 수 있을 것
같습니다. 그래서 유가 부분에서도
이렇게 [목을 가다듬음]
인플레이션이나 금리 부분에서 한번 더
짚어 드렸고 추가적으로 이제 또 어제
장에서 또 같이 봐야 될 부분은 이제
미국이랑이란 협상 뉴스가 또 이제
진전이 있었는데요 부분도 사실 유가를
떨어뜨리는 요인으로 또 추가 자격을
할 수 있거든요. 주식 시장에는 물론
복합적으로 작용을 하긴 하겠지만
적어도 이제 하방 압력으로 좀 작용할
수 있는 요인데 뭐 어떻게 이제
진행이 되고 있냐라고 보면 현재
협상이 뭐 단순한 대화 재결하기보다는
임시 휴전한 이후에 60일 안에 뭐
최종 합의를 추진하는 로드맵에 합의한
단계다로 진전이 되고 있는데 아직
최종 평화위가 체결된 건 아닌데
60일짜리 협상 프레임은 열려 있는
상태다라고 이제 보실 수 있을 것
같고 그 이제 지금까지 나온 이제
로드맵 어떤 이제 부분이 이제
키포인트냐라고 보면은 한네 갈래
정도의 인데요. 첫 번째는 이제 뭐
협수 거버넌스 구축 그래서 핵이나
제재 분쟁 해결 등을 나눠서 이걸
실무적으로 계속 논의하겠다라는게
나오고 있고 또 두 번째가 이제
호르무즈 해협 관리를 위해서 컨택
라인에 구축을 하겠다. 세 번째는
이제 레바논 관련 군산 충돌 방지
조정 채널도 만들겠다. 그 마지막으로
이제 핵문제 어떻게 하겠다 요런
정도네 가지 포인트인데 사실 시장
관점에서 보면 앞서 짚어드렸던
유가처럼 이제 호르무주 해업 내용이
좀 중요할 것 같습니다. 앞으로 이제
호르몬 통황하고 핵사찰은 아직 이행
확인이 좀 필요한 단계긴 하지만은
통황 정상화 기대가 커지면은 원유
공급 차질 우료도 줄어들기 때문에
유가 자체에는 하방 압력으로 작용할
수 있다. 그래서 근데 이제 앞으로의
관점 포인트는 그래도 호르무주가
열리느냐 다치냐 이것보다는 열리는데
어떤 조건으로 열리느냐 그게 이제 좀
트래킹 포인트가 될 수 있을 것
같습니다. 그 이제 기업단 뉴스들도
특별한 뭐 호재 뭐 실적 발표는 한
두 군데 정도 아래 있어서 간단히
언급드리긴 할 텐데 일단 AI 메모리
기업들의 펀더멘탈 훼손이 확인된 건
아니라고 저는 이제 말씀을 드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다. 그래서 펀더멘탈
훼손이 확인된게 아니라 아니다라는
이제 대전 전제를 이제 깔고 기업단
이슈 좀 점검을 해 보면은 앞서 이제
섹터 쪽에 언급을 드리면서 방어
섹터는 상승했다라고 말씀을
드렸는데요. 우선 신고가 찍은 종목은
없기는 했습니다. 그리고 25빌리언
이상 시총 가진 기업들은 상승한
종목이 이제 오늘은 하나도 없었고요.
전면적인 하락의 중심은 명확히 이제
반도체랑 AI 인프라였는데 일단
빅테크 쪽부터 먼저 점검해 보시면
마이크로소프트랑 아마존 백은 모두
하락을 했습니다. 이제 근데
마이크로소프트가 왜 올랐냐라고 보면은
뭐 AI를 AI 관련해서 뭐 맞은
게뭐 맞았다라고 보기보다는 오늘 이제
매도의 타겟이 아무래도 반도체
쪼이었기 때문에 좀 마이크로소프트가
뭔가 잘했다라기보다는 좀 매도 타겟이
달랐기 때문에 상승을 할 수
있었다라고 볼 수 있을 것 같고 이제
반대로 어제 돈을 버는 기업이다라고
하면서 메모리 말씀드렸는데 마이크론과
샌디스크가 이제 금락을 했습니다.
그리고 웨스턴 디지털도 이제 어제
하락 추세이어서 8% 때 하락을
했고요. 장비주들도 이제 함께
밀렸습니다. 그리고 중간부에 보시면
이제 광 섹터 계속 미래 이익을 많이
반영하고 있는 좀 섹터 쪽인데
코일런트랑 루멘텀도 10% 7%대
하락을 했습니다.
또 이제 뭐 계속이 단위단위로 말씀을
드리고 있긴 한데 스페이스섹스도 좀
심리적으로 중요한 지표이긴 했거든요.
어제 이제 뭐 대규모 무담보체 발행
이슈가 나오면서 현금이 충분한
기업조차도 부채를 활용한다라는 점이
AI 인프라 투자랑 현금 흐름에 대한
불안으로 좀 확산이 됐다라고 볼 수
있을 것 같습니다.
어 뒷부분에 이제 뭐 부사장님께서
간단히 말씀 주시긴 하실 텐데 뭐
세레브러스 AI라고도 그 주주의
지난번에 이제 공무주로 발표를 해
주신 기업는 상장 첫 실적을 발표를
했고요. 매출이랑 연간 가이던스
예상보다 좋긴 했는데 이제 인프라 쪽
관련해서 부사장님 중요하게 보시는
지표가 이제 크로스 마진이거든요.
그래서요 부분에서 좀 가이던스가 좀
보수적으로 제기가 되면서 좀 시간
내로는 좀 안 좋은 이제 추세 보였던
거 같고 그리고 카니발 크루즈도
실적을 발표했습니다. 마찬가지로 이익
자체는 좀 예상보다 괜찮긴 했는데
마찬가지로 가이던스가 좀 시장 기대를
밑돌면서 주가가 한 5% 장 중에
하락을 했고요.
일단 그래서 전체 오늘 장 랩업을
드리면은 또 완전한 투매하기보다는 좀
피난처를 찾은 당이 장이었다라고
말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같고 이제
AI랑 반도체에 과하게 몰렸던 자금이
자꾸 이제 방어 섹터랑 퀄리티
대형주로 피난한 장이었다.
>> 그래서 이제 다만 바우도 그래서
막판에 플러스를 지키지 못했다면다는
점에서 이제 피난처는 있었지만
확신이나는 저가 매수장은 아니었고
그래서 이제 오늘 장마 마감한 후에
발표되는 마이크론의 어깨가 좀
무거워질 것 같다 정도로 정리될 수
있을 것 같습니다. 이상입니다.
감사합니다. 아까 우리 유리프로가 어
반도체 업에 대해서 하이닉스에 대해서
네티브를 설명해 주셨다는 애널리스트분
소개시켜 주셨는데 네
>> 어 그냥 곱수개 소리로 하는게 아니라
어떤 애널리스트가 어떤 톤으로 과거에
얘기해 왔는지를 보는게 현재 어떤
말씀을 하셨을 때 그 무게를 좀
예측하는데 굉장히 도움이 많이 되기
때문에 그분의 과거를 좀 리포트나
아니면 과거에 하셨던 인터뷰 이런
것들을 보면서 어 평소 가졌던 톤이나
입장을 좀 정리 하는 건 상당히
중요한 거 같습니다. [콧방귀] 그런
면에서 말씀해 주신 내용 조금 더
신뢰가 가고 유익했던 거 같습니다.
쭉 이제 저는 유리프로가이 저희이
가격 판 첫 번째 페이지를 말씀해
주실 때
>> 유가와 금리와 달러 인덱스는 꼭 보는
편인데 어 [콧방귀] 유가 금리 이런
것들은 아무래도 주식 시장이 좋은
순방향인데 달러 인덱스가 100
이하로 이제 잘 안 내려오는 공면으로
간 거 아닌가? 이게 금리 인하에
대한 기대가 싹 적로 멀리 사라지면서
더게 된 거 아닌가라는 생각을 좀 해
봅니다.
이부에서 미국 시장은 최호 부사장과
함께 좀 더 자세히 보기로 하고요.
가상 [목을 가다듬음] 재산으로 그럼
넘어가 보겠습니다. 준혁님 어떻게
해됐습니까?
>> 네. 가산자 말씀드리겠습니다.
가산자산 어제도 말씀 간단하게 한번
드렸지만 어제 제가 사모시장 관련된
이슈와 함께 빠지고 있다 이렇게
말씀을 드렸었는데 그 이면에 또
다양한 이유들이 또 있었더라고요.
그래서 그런 부분들 같이 소개시켜
드리면 될 거 같고 어제 사실 먼저
비트코인이 빠졌습니다. 어제 어
아시아 장에서 이미 63,000불을
어 깨고 내려오면서 62,000불
후반될 정도 거래가 되고 있다 정도
보시면 될 거 같은데요. 제가
월요일장을 커버를 못 드렸기 때문에
월요일장을 간단히 말씀드리면 월요일
날에 스트레디가 비트코인 추가적으로
500개 정도 어 샀습니다. 그리고
그거 더불어서 뭐이란 미국 그이란
미국 전쟁도 조금 어 그 완화되는
분위기 어 그리고 어 그런 분위기로
가다 보니까 어 가격한 65,000불
이상을 돌파했었는데요. 그 이후에
어제 사모시장 이슈도 나왔고 어제
새벽에 제가 그 이슈 그 이슈를
파악하지 못했지만 양자 컴퓨터
관련해서 트럼프 행정 명령이
있었습니다. 그런 부분들이 어 동시
겹치다 보니까 비트코인 가격이 흐름이
안 좋아졌다. 그 6만2,000불로
다시 회기했다라고 보시면 될 거
같은데이 결국 추세선 그 저항선이라고
하는 것들이 어 일직선이 아니라 어
약간 사선이 되는 부분들이 있기
때문에 시간이 지나면서 옆으로 어
약간 어 내려오게 됩니다. 그러니까
오른쪽 오른쪽 밑으로 우 우
우하향하하게 되는 그림을 그리게
되는데요. 그렇게 되면 저항선으로 어
맞이하게 되는 구간이 점점점 가격이
내려오게 됩니다. 어, 그런 부분들
감안했을 때 저항이 6만6,000불에
고정되는게 아니라 뭐 65,000불
그리고 64,000불 이렇게 시간이
지나에 따면 시간이 지남에 따라서
조금씩 내려올 수 있다는 점
참고하시면 될 거 같고요. 어, 방금
달르네스 설명해 주셨는데 달르네스가
기술적으로도 제가 그 제가 그냥 어,
고점과 고점을 이은 그 구간에서 봤을
때도 어, 지금이 돌파 박스권을
돌파하고 있는게 아닐까는 생각을
개인적으로 하고 있습니다. 그래서
고점과 고점을이었을 때 101 정도가
딱 그 저항선에 위치하고 있거든요.
그이 저항선을 예를 들어 돌파한다라고
하면 거의 108 정도 인덱스 그
레벨까지 올라 그 열려 있는 구간이기
때문에 이런 부분들은 위험 자산이
그렇게 선호되는 어 상황 아니지
않을까? 특히 비트코인 같은 어
환경에는 그렇게 좋지는 않은 환경인
거 같다라고 말씀드릴 수 있을 것
같습니다. 어 비트코인 표인 그레디
인덱스 보시면 낙단조공간에 현재
유지되고 있고요. 어 비트코인물
ETF 순수 유출도 그렇게 좋지
않습니다. 68밀 68m년 정도가
유출이 되다 보니까 계속해서 안 좋은
약세를 어 기록하고 있다.이 정도
보시면 될 거 같고요. 어, 제가
방금 달러 인덱스 설명을 드렸지만
어, 달러 인덱스를 제가 장기
시기월, 5년 정도 차트로 봤을 때,
어, 금, 그리고 비트코인 그리고
달러 인덱스만 이렇게 비교해 놓은
겁니다. 흰색이 달러 인덱스고요.
어, 주황색이 비트코인이고 그
파란색이 어, 금이다라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다.이 이 오른쪽 분면을
조금 보시게 되면 어 비트코인 그
달러 인덱스가 오르는 거랑 비트코인
그리고 금이 오르는 거랑 별로
상관없네라고 저희가 볼 수 있겠지만
어 오히려 이거를 반 나눠서 왼쪽과
오른쪽을 나눠서 볼 필요가 있다라고
제가 아까 오전에 오면서 느꼈습니다.
왜냐면 어 오른쪽에 있는 비트코인
가격은 어 이게 ETF 좀 오른쪽
초반 쪽 보면 그 비트코인이 ETF
현물 순유 그 처음에 승인이 되면서
확 들어온 수급도 있었고요. 그
반감기 이후에 어 18개월 그동안 그
계속해서 랠리가 나오기 때문에이
비트코인이 좋았던 계절과 안 좋았던
계절 좀 구분해서 볼 필요가 있다라고
생각을 했습니다. 어 그렇게 본다라고
한다라면 오른쪽에 있는 거는 달러
인덱스와 상관성이 좀 떨어진다라고
보는게 오히려 맞을 것 같고요. 어
왼쪽에 있는 보시면 달러 인덱스가
상승하는 구간에는 어 비트 가격이
그렇게 약 그렇게 크게 강세를 보이지
못하는 모습을 보이고 있습니다.
계절적인 요과 어 달러 인덱스가 같이
겹친 것이다라고 보면 될 거
같은데요. 어 22년쯤에 달러 그
비트코인 가격이 고점을 치고 내려오게
되면서 그리고 달러 그 패드가 금리를
확 올리게 되면서 어 그 달러인데서
급상승을 하게 되고 그 구간에서
비트코인이 계속 약세를 이어가는
모습을 확인하실 수가 있을 것
같습니다. 그 장 그런 흐름이 어
23년 정도까지 그러니까 비트코인을
저희가 어 고점에서 그 저점에서
바닥을 본 순간까지 그 구간
정도까지는 계속해서 달러 인덱스에
영향을 많이 미친다. 영향을 많이
받는다라고 해석하는게 전 좋을 것
같다라고 생각을 했습니다. 그래서
이번 구간에도 비슷하게 보면 될 거
같은데요. 달러 인덱스가 상승하는
구간 상승하기 높은 레벨에서 유지되는
구간까지는 계속해서 비트코인이
계절적과 어 빗 달러 인덱스가 같이
겹쳐서 좋지 않은 흐름을 보일 확률이
굉장히 크다 이렇게 보는 것이 좀
맞지 않을까 생각을 개인적으로 한번
해 봤습니다. 그래서이 오른쪽 분면과
왼쪽 분면을 나눠서 봐야 되는데 어
계절적인 요인과 달러 인덱스의 상승이
[목을 가다듬음] 겹치게 된다라고
하면 비트코인 가격이 그리고 금의
가격도 사실 그렇게 좋지 않다라고
보시는게 좋지 않을까 생각합니다. 어
오른쪽에 있는 거는 아까 제가
말씀드린 그 양자 컴퓨터 관련된
이슈입니다. 그래서 행정적으로
비트코인을 위협한다 이렇게 제가 써
놨는데 어제 아침에 나왔던 이슈고요.
어제 트럼프 대통령이 양자 컴퓨터
관련해서 두 가지 행정 명령이 사인을
했습니다. 어 25414411
그리고 251449
이게 두 가지 코드를 가지고 있는
행정 명령이라고 하는데 어 첫 번째는
민간과 학계가 협력 협력해서
28년까지 과학 연고를 수행할 수
있을만큼 강력한 양자 컴퓨터를
배치하는 거. 그리고 두 번째로는 어
정부 보안 전문가에게 표준 암호화를
예상보다 빠르게 할 수 있는 양자
시스템에 대비할 수 있도록 지시하는
거 두 가지 행정 명령이 있었습니다.
그래서 어제 양자 컴퓨터 관련된
기업들이 [목을 가다듬음]
굉장히 흐름이 좋았던 걸로 제가 어제
장세에서 좋았던 걸로 제가 기억을
하고요. 어 실제로 양자 컴퓨터가
많이 어 발전이 된다라고 하면 초기에
비트코인을 만들었던 초기의 비트코인
비트코인 자체가 해킹되지 않지만
비트코인을 보관하고 있는 지갑들이
해킹될 수 있는 가능성이 굉장히
농화하다. 지난 제가 지난번에 그
구글 관련 말씀드릴 때도 한번
언급드린 적이 있었지만 어 양자
컴퓨터가 나오게 된다라고 하면 그런
초기 있었던 지갑들이 좀 위험하기
때문에 그런 부분들이 비트코인에 조금
어 안 좋은 센티먼트로 덩달아서
작용하지 않았을까 하는 생각을
개인적으로 했기 때문에이 두 가지를
같이 가져왔습니다. 달러 인덱스와
양자법들를 말씀드렸고요. 어 주요 쪽
보시면 제가 시험 패럴이 어 암호화폐
1타 강사인가 이렇게 제가 제목을 어
농담스럽게 적어 놨습니다. 톰리가
수정으로 있는 펀트렛의 내부 보고서의
전략 헤드인 어 전략 그 전략 파트
헤드인 션 페럴이 지난해 말에 어
톰리가 강세장을 지속적으로 전망할 때
약세 전망을 하고 그 전망이 정확하게
어 그 조정 그 조정이 나오게 되면서
주목을 받았다라고 한번 말씀을 한번
드렸던 적이 있었던 거 같습니다.
12월 달에 톰리가 계속해서 말 그
어 강세로 갈 거다. 바로하로 바로
반증할 거다. 이렇게 말을 해줬지만
어 그 내부적으로는 어 서로 지금
말이 안 나오는 말이 바퀴 말이 어
다르게 말하고 있는 그런 구간에
있다. 서로 방향성을 못 잡고
있다라고 말씀드린 적이 있었는데요.
그 구간이 실제로 션 페럴이 말한
대로 정확하게 됐습니다. 그래서
왼쪽에 사진을 보시면 내부 고객한테
지금이 보낸 보고서에 어 비트코인은
베이스 케이스에서 6만 불러에서
6만5,000불 정도까지 하락할
확률이 굉장히 크고 1분기에 그리고
이더리움은 한 1800불 정도까지
썰을 확률이 굉장히 크다라고 나와
있는 여기 빨간색 박스 부분을 보실
수가 있을 것 같은데요. 정확히이
구간까지 저희가 온 것을 확인을 할
수가 있을 것 같고요. 이게 뭐 션
패럴이 정확하게 맞춰서 어 가격을
뭔가 시세를 조작했다 이런 느낌보다는
실제로 내부적으로 어 고객한테 보낸
그런 문서에는 이런 내용들이 담겨
있었고 어 션페럴이 그때 해명하기로는
어 톰리는 자기는 어 톰리는 전체적인
전 세계인 투자들을 대상으로 말을
하는 거고 나는 어 그 암호화폐
비중이 높은 고객을 대상으로 나는
이렇게 보내는 거기 때문에 조금 말이
다를 수 있다라고 언급을 해
줬었거든요. 그래서 그런 부분을
참고해서 보시면 될 거 같고 그때
당시에 [목을 가다듬음]
이런 전망도 했습니다. 우리는 지금
여기 오른쪽에는 그림을 보시면
되는데요. 여기 다양한 구간들에
다양한 구간들에 뭐 희망도 있고
긍정적 그리고 그 신뢰 이런 부분들도
있는데요. 여기에 우리는 N과 구간에
있다. 그래서 지금 어 실제 그
비트코인이 어 고점을 치고 나서
하락하고 나서 지금 약간 화가 나
있는 상태에
그 진입을 하고 있다라고 언급을 해
주면서 그때이 두 가지를
점망해줬습니다. 비트공 가격이 어느
정도까지 떨어질 것이다. 그리고
우리는 지금 앵거 구간에 있기
때문에이 상태에서 조금 더 계속
조정이 지속될 것이다라는 전망을 해
줬습니다. 그러면 어이 시험 페널이
이젠 어떻게 보고 있나를 저희가 다시
한번 살펴볼 필요가 있을 것
같은데요. 가격 전망도 하나 해
줬습니다. 어, 비트코인 이전
약세장처럼 극단적인 수준까지 폭락하진
않겠지만 현재 기간 투자들이 수요가
경고하게 받쳐주 받쳐줌에도 불구하고
한 48K 그니까 48,000불에서
52,000불 정도까지 하락할
가능성이 존재한다라고 해줬고 MBRB
기준으로 MBRB 그때 제가 말씀드린
비트코인이 가장 마지막으로 움직이던
실현 가격 그리고 실제로 지금
표시되고 있는 가격 그 차이를
말씀드리는 겁니다. 그 기준으로도
비트코인 평균 단가한 53,000불
정도까지 내려오게 된다라고 하면
적극적으로 매수해 볼 가치가 있다라고
설명을 해줬고요. 어, 최근의
청산으로 시장의 레버리지가 많이
해소된 점도 긍정적이다라고 말씀해
줬습니다. 그리고 사실이 부분은
중시에서도 어, 사실 어, 많이
수요가 없는 부분들이다라고 설명해
주는 것도 각과 유사하기 때문에 어,
반대체 쪽 쏠림이 있다라고 또 같이
설명해 주는 것과 어, 괴를 같이
한다라고 생각을 했고요.
마이크로스티지와 스트레티지 스트레치
관련된 리스크도 언급을 해 줬습니다.
시장에서 우려했던 스트레티지의
연세적인 폭락 리스크는 어 좀
단기적으로 많이 완화된 것으로
보인다라고 설명을 해 줬고
스트레티지가 자본 조달을 통해서 리
그 현금을 확보하려고 확중하려고 하는
노력을 보이고 있고 회사가 당장에
대규모 비트코인을 어 매도할 확률은
낫다라고 생각한다. 그렇다고
단기적으로 암호화폐 생태계로의 강력한
유입을 이끌한 뚜렷한 촉매질은 보이지
않는 상황이다라고이 중요한 마지막
문장을 해 줬고요. 매크로 분석을
하면서 일한 전쟁 등으로 인한
인플레이션은 일시적을 어 가능성이
굉장히 높지만 단기적으로 핵심 CPI
등의 지표는 계속해서 상승할 수
있다. 어 채권 시장은 9월 금리
인상 가능성까지 반영을 하고 있고
실제 인상 여부보다 연준의 어조와 어
그리고 매파 언조 어조가 매파적으로
변하거나 채권 시장이 신임 연준
의장을 테스트하는 과정 속에서
암호화폐를 포함한 어 다양한 위험
자산이 어 단기적으로 사격을 잃을 수
있는 환경이다라고 판단한다 이렇게
언급을 해 줬습니다. 그래서 세
가지가 있을 것 같은데 결국엔
비트코인이 약세가 조금 지속될 거
같다. 그리고 그 테스트는
48,불에서 52,000불까지 갈
수가 있다. 하지만 스트레티지가
대규모 비트코인을 매도하면서 그런
환경이 어 발생하진 않을 것 같다라고
언급을 해줬고 결국 매크로 환경에서
지금 케빈 씨가 금리를 인상할 수
있다라는 그 공포감이 계속해서 확산이
되고 있는 와중에 암호화폐 같은 어
위험자 위협받을 수 있다라고 말을 해
준 거 같고요. 그래서 아까 말이
나온 MBRB 차트입니다. 왼쪽에
있는 피델리티에서 어 나와 준 그
내준 자료 있네요. 어 이게 MBRB
기준으로 실제 어 사람들의 평균
단가와 어 실제 표시되고 있는 가격의
그 비율을 따졌을 때 그게 1 아 0
정도가 내려오게 된다라고 하면 그게
어 가치가 좀 저평가가 되고 있는 어
그런 구간이다라고 이해를 하시면 될
거 같은데요. 어쨌든 그 구간상으로는
어 지금 그 정도 많이 내려왔다.
53,000 불리 그 구간이기 때문에
그 구간까지 많이 내려왔다.이 이
정도로 해석하시면 될 거 같고 결국에
그럼 케비너 씨가 지금 금리를
확실하게 인상시킬 것인가? 제가
그거를 한번 간단하게 제가 보면 좋을
것 같아서 가져왔는데 씨는 트림드
인플레이션 레이트 트림 그니까 어
절사 평균 어 PC를 보겠다라고
언급을 한 바 있습니다. 그래서 그
절사 평균 PC 레이트를 보게
된다라고 하면 어 프레드 기준에서는
이게 완만하게 그냥 내려오고 있는
수준으로 보이 보이고는 있거든요.
그래서 22년에 인플레이션 레이트가
거의 5% 정도까지 올라갔을 때 어
이후로 어 점진적으로 좀 내려오고
있는 그림을 보여주고 있습니다. 결사
평균이라 거는 상위 31%를 그냥 어
무작 그냥 위에서 자른 어 그 수치다
이렇게 보시면 될 거 같습니다. 바로
밑에 있는 거는 어 US 그 미국
2년물에 어 일반적인 지금 금리
상황과 그리고 바로 밑에 있는 건
인플레이션 소합입니다. 인플레이션
소합은 어 미래 지금 투자자들이
인플레이션이 얼마나 올라갈 것
같은지에 대한 배팅을 하고 있다
정도로 저는 해석을 했는데요. 그래서
위에 있는 파란색 차트가 2년 불이고
어 밑에 있는게 어 노란색 차트가
인플레이션 수합입니다. 그래서
인플레이션 2년물은 지금 실제로 많이
올라가고 있는 흐름을 저희가 계속해서
트래킹을 해 왔지만 인플레이션 수합
같은 경우에는 그렇게 많이 올라가는
채세는 보이지 않는 거 같습니다.
그래서 오히려 고점을 치고 꺾여가는
그림을 오히려 보이고 있어서 그 밑에
있는 검색 차트를 보시면 실질적인 어
그 인연물 어 국채 수익률을 보게
된다라고 하면 어 한 2%에 아직 좀
못 미치는 그런 흐름이 나온다라고 어
펀스트레이드에서이 션페러리 관련해서
지금 이게 전망을 해 준 거거든요.
그래서 결국 페럴이 하고 싶은 말은
지금 어이 연준 의장이 시장을
테스트하고 있는 그런 과정 속에서
결국에 인플레이션이 지금 올라가는게
어 그 인연물이 올라가는게 인플레이전
때문에 올라가는 것이 아니라 어 실질
성장 때문에 올라간다는 것을
케빈너씨가 실적으로 판단하게 된다라고
하면 2분기에 어 이제 조금 금리
인상이 아니라 조금 완화적인 좀
도비시한 어 그런 어 정식을 펼칠
확률이 굉장히 크다. 그렇게 된다라고
하면 암호화폐 같은 경우에도 그렇고
위험 자산 같은 경우에도 그렇고 조금
2분이
반기에 조금 좋아질 확률이 좀 크지
않을까 이런 식으로 전망을 해
줬습니다. 그래서 밑으로 내려와서
보시면 그냥 재미로 보는 어 26년
어 가상자선 전망이라 써 놨는데요.
비트코인은 연말까지 한 11만
5,000불 정도 그리고 이더리면 4
4,500불 정도까지 회석할 그
회복할 수 있지 않을까 하는 전망을
해줬습니다. 거의 그래서
53,000불 기준으로 보게 된다라고
거의 100% 이상의 상승률을
연말까지는 보여 주지 않을까 이렇게
연 그 그 예상을 해 준 건데요.
결국에 또 약속의 10월입니다. 어
결국에 하반기에 좋아질 것이다라고
지금 봐주고 있는거다 보니까
실질적으로 지금 저희가이 션페럴이
말해 준 어 이념물 금리 그리고
인플레이션 수업이 자료가 맞다라고
하면 인플레이션이 그렇게 지금
공격적으로 어 그 T비너시가 금리
인상을 할 정도로 높은 건 아니다라고
제가 판단이 되는데요. 어쨌든 저희가
어떻게 지켜지어 진행이 되는지는
실질적으로 케빈 씨가이 PC 트렌트
PC만 보고 결정을 하는 건 아니기
때문에 어이 부분을 참고해서 봤을
때는 그럴 가능성이 높지만 다른
부분들도 한번 저기 검토해 볼 가능성
검토해 볼 필요성이 있는 거 같고요.
어쨌든 어 작년 12월에 정확하게이
시장을 전망을 했었고 앞으로 보
앞으로 보는 시장은 이렇게 됐었다라고
하는 좀 안내해 드리고 싶어서 어
말씀드렸습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 비트코인이나 이더리움에
직접적으로 투자하시는 분이 아닌
아니시다 하더라도 달러 인덱스라든지
아니면 금리 어 전망이라든지 오늘
배울 내용이 상당히 많았고 그
결정이나 움직임에 대한 논리적
근본들을 자세히 설명해 주셔서 도움이
많이 됐던 거 같습니다. 저도 다시
한번 보도록 하겠습니다. 제가 모닝
브리프 1부 진행하다 보면 변동성이
커지고 주식 시장에 하락할 때 훨씬
더 많은 분들이 공시간 때 보고
계시거든요. 오늘 보니까
1,350분이 넘으세요. 아, 시장이
많이 흔들리다 보니까 좀 관심도
있으시고 걱정이 되실 것 같은데
이부에서 더 많이 나게 얻어가시라면서
일부 마치도록 하겠습니다. 일부 함께
해 주신 채널 여러분 감사드립니다.
Hm.
เฮ
>> [음악]
[음악]
>> 안녕하세요. 홍한 투자의 여정을
채소리 투자무과 함께 찰리 모니버리퍼
오늘 6월 24일 수요일 2부 순서
[목을 가다듬음] 시작하도록
하겠습니다.
자 어 시장의 방송 크고
미국 시장을 보면 이제
시장 때문에 미국 시장에
커지고 있다. 이런 느낌이죠. 예,
그렇습니다. 한국 시장이 선주을
받으면 미국 시장도 선주을 받고 한국
시장이 오르면 미국 시장도 오르고
아, 그런 느낌입니다. 그 이유가
아, 최근 글로벌 장세를 이끌고 있는
핵심 종목들이 한국과 미국에 보돼
있는데 특히 이제 반도체 쪽에 영향이
크다 보니까 그런 현상들이 나타나는
거 같고요. 올해 사실 어 뭐 개인
투자자들이나 기관 투자자들 성과를
보면 반도체 주식을 어떻게 어
투자했느냐 어떻게 가져갔느냐에 따라서
어 성패가 극과 극을 달리는 거
같습니다. 그래서 기존 뭐 개인
투자자분들도 이렇게 만나보면은 M7
이렇게 몇 년 동안 들고 있다가
25년까지는 그런대로 좋았는데
26년에는 뭐 안 좋은 성과를 내고
있고 반면에 반도체로 잘 어
포트폴리오를 리싱 하신 분들은 어
성과가 꽤 좋은 어 그런 어 양극화를
달리고 있는 거 같습니다. 앞으로도
저는 마찬가지일 것 같아요. 그래서이
하락을 어떻게 보느냐 그리고이 하락에
대해서 어떻게 대응하느냐 이게 상당히
어 관건이 될 거 같은데요. 어 바로
시작하면요. 필반 주수가 뭐 핵심일
것 같습니다. 우리나라에서 삼성자
하이닉스가 핵심이듯이. 그런데
그 제가 계속해서 그 필반질수에
EPS하고 밸류에이션을 어 체크를 해
보는데
약간 필반 지수의
그 밸루에이션 자체가 아 고점 수준에
다다르면은 가격도 어 역사적 신고가를
쓰면서 조정이 나타나는 그런 흐름은
이전에도 있었고요. 그리고 어
이러저러한 이유들로 인해서 뭐 미일한
전쟁이라든지 유가 금리 상승이라든지
뭐 뭐 스페이스 X 상장을 납둔
우려라든지 이런 요인들로 인해서 빠질
때는 항상 밸류에이션이 고점 수준이
있었습니다. 이번에도 좀 어 그런
경향들이 경향이 나타났는데 22일
기준으로 해서 어 필반 지수의
PER이 29.3배까지 3배 수준까지
올라갔었는데 이전에 그 차트를
보시면은 노란선이
일반질수의 PER인데 이게 28.8배
뭐요 정도 수준까지 어 전에 어
고점을 기록했었다가 이번에
28.8배를 배를 넘어서 29배까지
가니까 어 지수 자체도 어
신고가인데다가
밸루에이션 부담도 분명히 있는
상태였었고요.
어 거기다가 한국 시장의 삼성전
하이닉스 그리고 좀 마이너 뭐 뭐
금리 인상에 대한 향후 어 좀 과격한
전망들이 어 BOFA에서 나오면서
이러저러한 이유들 때문에
하락을 설명을 하는데 결국에는 쏠리면
현상 그리고 어 가격 부담 밸류에이션
부담 이런 부분들이 복합적으로
나타나지 않았나 싶습니다. 그래서
오래 들어서이 한 10% 내외 정도
빠지는 현상들이 좀 자주 나타나기도
하고 반면에 10% 단기간에 오르는
현상들이 어 나타나기도 하는데
과열권에서 나타나는 뭐 자연스러운
현상이라고 생각을 하고 있고요.
최근 조정 사례를 계속해서 업데이트를
하는데 지난 3월에 미일한 전쟁으로
10% 정도 3일에 걸쳐서 하락을 한
적이 있고요. 5월에 잠깐 10%는
아니지만 이틀에 걸쳐서 한 6.4%
정도 하락 어 사례들이 있습니다.
그리고 6월 초에 6월 4일 5일에
2.2% 10.3% 이틀간에 한
12.2%서
하락한 사례들이 있었는데 이때가 이제
금리 영향 또는 스페이스 X 상장
우려 요런 얘기들이 있었고
어제
일반 지수가 7.9% % 어 고점에서
하락을 했는데
단기 과열이나 밸류에이션 부담으로
저는 어 보고 있습니다. 그래서 6월
달에 이렇게 급등락하는 가운데 그럼
필반 지수는 지금 어떤 상태에
있을까? 6월 달만 보면은 6월
상승률이 한 5.1% 정도 어 상승을
기록을 하고 있고요. SMP 500
-2.8% 나스닥 -5.1% 1% 셀
1.9% 다우 1.2% 코스피도
참고로 적어 놨는데 코스피는
-3.2% 수준입니다. 그래서 어
6월 달만 보면은 주요 지수 중에서
가장 강한데 종목들은 더
지수가 5.1% 오르는 동안 어 더
강했었습니다. 어 마이크론이 뭐
8.3% 3% 오른 상황에서 어
ASML이나 램리서치 어플라이드
모트격이 10에서 30% 올랐고요.
인텔도 15%를 낳고 마벨
테크놀로지도 36% 저장 장치로
일컬러지는 샌디스크나 웨슨 디지털
C게이트도 뭐 10에서 한 20%
이상씩 이렇게 오르면서 분명히 그
가격에 대한 부담은 종목에서도
있었다라고 생각을 하고 있고 그 종목
그 가격 부담이 어 쏠림으로
나타났는데 그 극명하게 나타나 대조가
되는 부분들은 들은 어 6월 달에
기타 시 시 시총 대형주를 보면은
M7이 어 플러스가 난 종목이 하나도
없습니다. 다 한 자릿수 중후반에서
어 두 자릿수까지 이렇게 빠져
있고요. 그래서 극심한 양극과 극심한
솔림들이 반도체 지수, 반도체 지수
내 종목으로 어 나타났다라고 보시면
될 거 같고 기타 어 여기에서 조금
애매하게 어 뭐 구경제에 위치한 주요
종목들은 그럭저럭 그 선방하는
모습들이 관찰이 [콧방귀] 되는데 어
특히 그 금융주들이 어 JP모건이나
뱅커 보니카 그리고 마이크 아 저기
저기 모건 스탠이 이런 금융주들이 한
자릿수 후반에서 두 자릿수 정도
이렇게 상승세를 보였고 그리고
방어주고 일컬러지는
일리가 뭐 0.2% 정도 그리고 존슨
앤 존슨이 6.1% 그리고 그 밖에
AI 인프라와 직간접적으로 관련되
있는 캐터킬러가 12.4%
유나이티드스가 7.6%요 %요 정도
올랐습니다. 그래서 미국 시장을
6월에 좀 정의를 해 본다면 어
빅테크는 완전히 소해됐고 반도체는
굉장히 좋았고 중간에 어 고경제 주식
방어 주식들은 말 그대로 선방했다.
아직 이렇게 좀 볼 수 있을 것
같고요. 오늘 나온 아 그 오늘 그
미국 시장
끝나고 나오는 마이콘 테크날로가 다시
한번 이런 추세를
더욱더 분명하게 할 수 있을 거라고
저는 생각을 하고 있습니다. 그래서
종목별 등락 보면은 매번 드리는
말씀이자 그 필반 지수가 한 종목처럼
이렇게에 오르는 현상들이 어 자주
관찰이 되고 있고 그 가운데서도 어
모멘텀이 더 센 거는 더 많이 오르고
약한 거는 좀 덜 오르고 하는
현상들이 나오고 있습니다. 어제 같은
경우는 그간 세게 올랐던 어 종목들
위주로 어 두 자릿수 어 하락을
보이는 현상들이 나타났고 반면에 덜
오른 종목들 같은 경우는 어 덜
빠지는 어 상황이 관찰이 됐습니다.
그래서 메모리 위주로 마이크론이 한
13% 정도 하락을 했고 저장 장치
쪽에 샌디스크나 웨스트 디지털 그리고
시게이트 이런 것들도 한 자리수 어
두 자릿수까지 어 빠졌고요. 그동안
장비주들도 상당히 좋았는데 램리서치가
9% 어플라이드 머티리얼이 한 8%
정도 어 하락하는 현상이
관찰됐습니다.
6월 등락률 보면은 어제 빠졌음에도
불구하고
어 일반 지수 내에서는 그래도
모멘텀이 강한 종목들은 어 투자수
이상 상승한 종목들이 아까 말씀드렸던
대로 다수 어 포함이 돼 있다 이렇게
보시면 될 것 같습니다.
그리고 이것저것 조금 그 급락이
나왔을 때 점검하는 지표들을 좀
봤습니다. 그래서 지금 시장에서 약간
화두가 되고 있는 부분들이 어 향후
금리 인상에 대한 아 논란들인데
일단 그 물가를 자극하는 유가는 어
현재 73불까지 어 내려와 있는
상황이고요.
이란 협상이 지금 진전이 있는
상황이기 때문에이 부분은 좀 더
내려올 수 있지 않을까라고 생각하는데
일부 시각에서는
어 생산 시설이 복구되는 데까지 오래
걸리기 때문에 쉽게 내려오지 않을 수
있다라고 얘기를 하고 있지만 결국 제
생각에는 주가는 그 이상을 어 보고
가기 때문에 유가는 크게 지금
상황이라면 문제는 되지 않을 거라고
보고 있고요. 10년물 금리가
4.5% 정도에서 어 등락을 하고
있는데이 부분이 앞으로 그 경 나올
경제 지표나 아니면 물가 지표에
따라서 어 영향을 받을 것 같습니다.
25일 내일 밤 9시 반에 어
발표되는
ORPC 지금 컨센서스가 헤드라인이
4.1% 근원이 3.4%인데 4%인데
아 전널 대비 헤드라인은 0.3%
포인트 그리고 근원은 0.1% 1%
포인트 올라갈 걸로 예상이 되고
있는데 내일 아침 어 새벽 내일 아침
5시에 일단 어 마이콘 테크놀로지
실적이 좀 잘 나오게 되면은이 25일
밤에 어 발표되는 PC 컨센서스 PC
물가 지표는 어 그냥 지나가는 지표가
되지 않을까 싶습니다. 어차피 5월에
유가가 높았던 구간이기 때문에요 정도
더 나오는 거는 시장에서 어 센대로만
나오면은 용인하고 지나가지 않을까
싶고요. 그리고 미국 시각으로 어
우리 장 마감 후에 24일 장 마감
후에 마이콘 테크날로지 실적에 발표가
되는데 어제 고점 대비 고점
기록했다가 13.2% % 정도 하락을
하면서
아 10배까지
거의 갔었다가요. 어 어제 13%
하락하면서 어 9.6배 어 지금
거래가 되고 있는 상황입니다. 총인열
기준으로 오면은
5월 분기에
어 매출 총인율이 81.8%로 8%로
컨센이 형성되고 있고요. 그리고 어
그 차분기 어 매출 총액률이
83.5%로 5%도 어 소폭 올라가는
거로 돼 있는데요 부분이 좀 핵심일
것 같습니다. 지난부 지난번에도
어이 매출 총익률 어 가지고 좀 그
얘기가 나오면서 어 실적 발표하자마자
좀 하락한 상황이 발생을 했었거든요.
그래서여 부분이 어떻게 그 제시가
되느냐가 중요한데 대체로 그
컨센서스는 어 상의할 거 같은데 스
컨센서스가 좀 높게 형성되 있기
때문에 상의할지는 좀 봐야 될 거
같은데 저 개인적으로는 좀 정황상으로
봤을 때는 어 긍정적으로 보여집니다.
그 연반기금 금리에 대한 그 얘기들이
조금 나오고 있는데 어제 한국
장에서도 어 뱅크니카가
리서치 자료에서 연내 세 번 분리
인상 할 수 있다는 뉴스플로들이
나오고 있는데이
뱅커니카가 발관한 미 그이 그 연내
세 번 금리 인상 자료가
발표된 거가 22일 그까 뉴욕
시간으로 으로 22일
아침이었더라고요.
그러니까 이게 한 이틀 전
자료입니다. 근데 어제 어 시장이
빠지니까 아 실제로 미국 시장에서 자
22일 장 전에이 발표가이 자료가
발표가 됐고 22일 시장에서는 크게
영향력이 없다가 어제 한국 시장이 좀
빠지면서이
자료가 조금 부각을 받았는데 어 뱅크
아메리카의 주장은 9월 10월
12월에 10 그 금리 인상을
25피씩 할 수 있다는 어
주장이고요. 그 주장에 근거는
원문을 제가 받아보지 못해 가지고
월스트 전널에서만 나온 기사로만
요약을 했는데 어 견조한 경계 경제
지표하고 어 그리고 예상보다 매파적인
연준의 스탠스 때문에 어 자기네들은
세 번 정도 금리 인상을 할 것
같다라는 주장을 하고 있습니다.
근데이 하우스에서 그 플로우 자료가
매주 나오고요. 그리고
그
펀드메이저 서웨이가 한 달에 한 번씩
나오는데 작년 하반기부터 계속해서 그
시장에 대해서 그 컨트레리언 전략을
어 제시를 했었습니다. 그래서 제
느낌으로는 컨트레리언 전략 하에서 어
서포팅할 수 있는 아 근거를
근거로서 어 이런 부분들이 제시되지
않았나 하는 생각이 있고요. 어
그렇게 생각하는 이유는 지금 FMC
이후에서 이후에 패드와치에서 어
추정하는
그 사람들이 예상하는 어 금리 인상의
어떤 횟수나 시점을 볼 때 일단 7월
29일에
열리는 FMC 미팅에서는 동결로
나오고요. 62.6% 6% 환경로
그리고 26년 9월 16일부터 어
인상으로 나오긴 하는데 이것도 뭐
50%.5%로
5%로 인상 확률이 그다지 높지
않습니다. 그것도 제가 볼 때는 어
그때까지의 어떤 상황이나 이런 것들이
어 전부 다 좀 반영이 그 어 돼야
될 거 같고요. 그리고
그 FMC에서의 약간 연준의 호키시안
스탠스만으로 지금 어 시장에서 이렇게
예상하고 있는데 계속해서 물가에
이렇게 영향을 미치는 유가하고 그리고
어 경제 지표가 어떻게 좀 나오느냐를
계속 관찰해야 될 거 같고
지금 상황에서 어 세 번은 저는 조금
어 과하다는 생각입니다.
이고음 그 피어브리드 인덱스 계속
보고 있었는데음
최근에 보면은
그 주가가 상승함에도 불구하고 어
계속해서 피어 영역이 있었거든요.
어제 그 [목을 가다듬음]
전체적인 미국 시장 자체가 안
좋아지면서
익스트림 피어로 조금 더 옮겨가긴
했습니다. 그래서 지금 보면은 28
정도를 기록을 하고 있고 옆에 엔리드
인덱스하고 S&P 500을 보면은
SP 500이 이제 빨간선이고 엔드
인덱스가 어 파란선인데 이게 그
이전에 추위를 보면은
같이 가는 모습이었는데 어 이번에는
그 괴리가 어 삐어 쪽 삐어 영역에
있음에도 불구하고 어 SP500은
올라가는 그런 좀 다번 스가
나타나는데 이게 결국에는이 안에 있는
어 비어인 그리드 인덱스를 구성하는
지표들이 얼마나 쏠려 있나 그리고 어
국채 수익률이 지금 어느 정도
수준인가 요런 것들을 반영을 하고
있기 때문에 피어 영역으로 어 지금
와 있는 상황이고요.
특히나 이제 쏠림 현상에 대해서 아주
안 좋은 영향을 미치면서 어 비어
영향에 어 도달했다고 보시면 될 것
같습니다. 근데 어쨌든 그 경험상으로
또 그 패턴 상으로 보면은이 피어
영역 특히 이제 익스트리얼 피어
영역으로 어 더 가면 갈수록 언제나
하는 말 드리는 말씀이지만 위험은
감소한다. 그래서 어 분할 매수 어
관점으로 대응하면은 어 지나가 보면은
그
시장이 정성화됐을 때
괜찮은 성과를 낼 수 있다라고 말씀을
드리고 있습니다. 이번에도 저는 뭐
포트폴리오만
핵심 종목으로 잘 구성을 하고 있고
또 리밸런싱 할 기회가 없으셨던
분들이 어 다시 리밸런싱을 한다면은
어 괜찮은 성과로 이어지지 않을까라고
생각을 하고 있습니다. 그리고 빅스
보면은 어제 이제 그 금 그 주가들이
많이 빠졌기 때문에 질수도 한
19.5 5 정도로 올라와 있는 그런
상황입니다. 이게 뭐 더 갈지 안
갈지는 모르겠지만 어 과열을 어느
정도 지금 시키는 상태고 시킨 상태고
밸루에이션 부담을
아 그 급락에 의해서 조금 어느 정도
완화진 상태기 때문에음
그리고 어 마이콘 테크놀로지 어
실적이 어 좀 긍정적으로 나올
것이라고 좀 보기 때문에 요런
부분들은 좀 회수가 되지 않을 것
같고요. 그래서 이것저것
이전에 어 필반 지수가 빠졌던 거하고
어 지금 필반 지수의 상황 그리고
전체적인 미국 시장 상황하고 어
네크로 사항을 좀 짚어 드렸는데 어
결론적으로 어 반도체 솔림하고 가격
밸루에이션의 과열을 좀 시키는
과정이라고 생각을 하고 있고 어
마이크론 실적 발표 이전에 미리
선조정을 받은만큼 내년 내일 어 새벽
5시에 발표되는 마이크론 실적이
낙폭 회복의 전환점이 되지 않을까라고
생각합니다. 이상입니다.
>> 네. 감사합니다.
어제 우리 신랑이 먼저 됐다고 하고
미국 시장까지 이제 영향을 주면서
많은 분들이 하고 있습니다.
그 미국 랩 지난주에 상원되고 지금
모집이에요.
>> 예. 모집입니다. 금요일까지
모집이고요. 다음 주 월요일부터 어
운용 개시할 예정입니다.
어제담처럼 무기 예
지난주에 비가려
되고
좋은 주식을 어쨌든 싸게 놓은 거
그럼요. 그러면 그럴수록 이제
업사이드 포텐셜이 더 높아지니까요.
예.
>> 근데 그거는 우리가이 주식이라는게
동승자산이다 보니까
>> 예.
>> 이제이 짧은 참 맞추는 거 저 같은
경우에 맞춰 보려고 애를 쓰시당
같은 경우에 이격도 한 135절이
가니까 아 조절이 맞는구나.
>> 근데 이격이 그 130까지 올라갈지도
누구도 모르는 거잖아.
>> 그렇죠. 예. 맞습니다. 그렇게
갈지도 모르고 그래서 어느 시점에
다시 또 이렇게 빠졌질도 모르는데
그게 어떻게 보면 문이거를 통해
저희가 국내나 미국이나 다 지난주에다
전하냐 이쪽
빠져줍니다. 찾아보면
그 부분은
마이크
>> 예 마이크 예정도면
잘 늘리시는지 모르겠는데
예 이렇게 하시죠.
요걸로 뭐 잠시 요렇게 얘기하면 될
거 같긴 한데 자 그래서 어 그 짧은
변동성에 대한 얘기 다시 말씀드리면
그거는 운이에요. 솔직히 맞춰
보려고는 하지만 운입니다. 그래서
지난주에 다행히 저희가 국내 미국 다
랩을 목표 전환을 다 청산을 했고
이번 주 모집이 들어가고 또 어떤
회사는 다음 주부터 모집이 들어가는데
그래서 뭐 포카이나
고스토판에서 운 좋은 사람 피하라고
그럼 제가 말씀도 드렸었는데
[목을 가다듬음]
>> 다행히 저희가 매일 아침 이렇게 모닝
브리퍼도 하고 별주 버전도 하고
이렇게 저희가 공부한 거 어 함께
나누는 그런 채널을 운영하다 보니까
어 그래서 우리한테 이렇게 운이 좋게
작용을 하나 그런 생각도 사실 들긴
합니다.
그래서 어 결국은 두 가지인데이
첫 번째는 무조건 포트폴리오를 잘
짜야 되고 그죠?
>> 예. 사장님이 강 강조하시나? 일단
포트폴리오를 잘 짜야 되는데
피트린치도 예전 책을 읽어 보면
피트린치가 턴어라운드 주식 그리고
고성장 주식 중심으로 포트폴리오를
짜고 있다 보니까 어 시장 대비
베터가 크다고 얘기했었어요. 베타가
커서 떨어질 때는 좀 확 어 시장보다
더 떨어지고 올라갈 때 더 올라갔다
그런 [목을 가다듬음] 얘기를 해
놓으셨었는데
이게 좋은 종목으로 쏠려 있는데 이게
쏠린게 그냥 내 돈만 가지고 투자하고
있으면 괜찮은데이 해치 펀드들은 롱을
하면서 내돈보다도 훨씬 많은 수량을
롱을 잡고 매수를 잡고 안 좋다고
생각하는 거를 갖다가
주식을 빌려서 때려놓는 그런
레버리지를 많이 쓰다 보니까 걔네들도
좋은 주식이 빠지면 어쩔 수 없이 어
로스컷을 해야 되는 상황이 발생하고
어 신용을
개인 투자자들도
좋은 주식이 확 빠지게 되면 어쩔 수
없이 반대 매매가 나오게 되고 그게
변동성을 좀 야기시키는 요인이기
때문에 그래서 그냥 레버리지를 안
하시는 분들 입장에서는 시장이 왜
이래 어 방정맞게 이렇게 확 올라다가
확 내렸다가 왜 이러나 싶긴
하시겠지만
제가 그 부분을 좀 알기 위해서 고유
운용을 하러 가지고 최부사장도 예전에
증권사 고유 프럼 트레이딩 하러
가봤었지만
그런 하우스에서도 또 월간 로스관
이런게 있어요. 월반 로스카 분비
로스카 그러면 좋은 주식 질러 놨는데
일정 수준 이상 빠지면 기계적으로
매도를 또 해야 됩니다. 그런
부분들이 아 이런 부분이 줄까예
변동성을 이야기시키구나.
일반 뮤얼 펀드에서는 그런 식으로 안
하거든요. 안 하는데이 프트레이딩이나
해치 펀드나 그다음에 어 CFD
계좌라든지 신용을 많이 쓰는 그런
레버리지 투자자들 때문에
종목의 변동성이 이렇게 심하게
나타나는구나. 예. 그 부분을 좀
이해하게 됐고요. 그러면 그 선수들이
어쩔 수 없이 밑에서 팔아야 될 때
좋은 주식을 싸게 하는 그런 기회가
되기 때문에
그 부분을 잘 이해하시면 저희 같은
경우에는 이번 주 모집한단 말이죠.
>> 예. 이번 좀 금하신다.
>> 그래서
좋은 주식을 갖다가 또 이렇게 싸게
살 수 있는 기회를 주는 거 같아서
참으로 우리한테는 운이 좋게
작용하구나. 예. 그런 생각을 하고
있습니다. 자, 그런데 어, 왜 하필
지금 빠지느냐? 왜 하필 지금
빠질까?요 부분은 이제 좀 우리가
생각을 해 봐야 되죠. 예. 그
부분에 대해서는 최근에 뭐 말씀드린
대로 스페이스 X라는 거대한 공룡이이
상장된 것도 있긴 하지만 아무래도
투자자들이 과거에 그 레버리지
투자자들은 시장이 무너지면서 본인들의
포지션이 강제 청산당하는 거가 제일
두려운 거예요. 그래서 나름대로 많은
공부를 할 건데 어 바로 앞전에 제가
설명드린 것처럼이 큰 큰 조력은 언제
왔었나?
언제 왔었나라고 봤더니 연준 의장이
교체되고 나면 뭐 조정이 왔었다.
근데 그것도 제가 발라서 보니까
연준회의장이 교체됐다고 어 항상
조정이 있었던게 아니라 이게 금리
하락기에 왔느냐 아니면 금리 인상기에
왔느냐 그리고 금리를 하락하는 와중에
왔다라고 생각했는데 와 가지고 금리를
인상을 했었던 사람이 앨런 그리스이
1987년도에
8월 달에 부임하자마자 9월 달에
금리 인상했더니 10월 달에
블랙만데이가 오는 그런 일들이 여러
차례 있다 보니까
어 걔네들 입장에서는 지금
패드워치에서 나오든 나오든 이게 한
번 인상이다든 두 번 인상이다든 세
번 인상이다. 야 이게 그렇게 과거의
역사적인 사례라 안 물려서 지금이
어떻게 보면 약간 회색 콧불수가 저
앞에 있는데 얘가 달려올까 안
돌려올까
그 부분에 있어서
그냥 내 돈 투자하는 사람은 상관이
없어요. 달려가도 상관이 없어요.
어차피 빠졌다가 다시 다 회복할
거니까. 근데 레버리지를 쓰는 선수들
입장에서는이
회석 부풀수가 근처까지만 와도 시장에
와장착하면서
원인들의 포지션이 다 털리기 때문에
얘네들한테는 지금 상당히이
상황이 어 약간 넓버스하게 만드는
시장입니다. 그래서 최근에 어이기
안 나는 종목들은 와르로 무너지는
그런 모습이 나오고 있고 위험자에
대한 투자 심리를 가장 잘 알려주는
코인 시장도 마찬가지죠.
코인 시장도 무너지는 모습이다.
그래서 어제 아침에 지금은 솔직히
약간 약세장으로 진입한거다라고
한 3, 4개월짜리 약세장이 될 수
있다. 그런 말씀을 드린게이 금리
인상이라는게
우리한테는 레버리지를 쓰지 않는
우리한테는 뭐 저게 그렇게 뭐
중요한가?
근데 레버리지를 쓰는 선수들한테는
제일 무서운 것 중에 하나.
그래서 그런 조정이 있고 어 다행인
거는 지금 SP 500도 그렇고
우리나라 코스피도 그렇고 어 PR나
이제 멀티플이 되게 착해요.
멀티플이 착하기 때문에 그래서
이번에도 이격 조정 130에서 다시
1한 전쟁 대독을 했었고 그때 2월
27일 날 130 넘었다가 예 한
방에 20% 빠지면서 이격 조정 딱
끝나고 나니까 그러고 나서 쌍바닥
치고 다시 올라왔잖아요.
이번에도 비슷한 형태에 그런 기술적인
조정 정도 보이는데 어 그 레버리지
선수들이 이제 어 공격적으로 아 이제
끝났네. 이제 코플소가 저기 왔다가
돌아가네 하면서 언제 돌아올 건가를
또 우리가 생각해 봐야 되는데 언제
돌아올까? 언제 돌아오나? 7월
29일. 아 이거 여기서 금리
인상하는 거 아니야? 그다음에 9월
16일. 예.요 요 부분이 있기
때문에 그 레버리지 선수들이
돌아오기에는 7월 말까지는 잘 못
돌아옵니다. 제 생각에 못 들어오고
저는 언제 돌아온다고 생각 언제
돌아온다고 생각하냐면
자이 금리 인상을 할 수밖에 없는
상황은 최근에 2.4까지 때려졌다가
4.2까지 까지 올라 CPI를 보면
아 이거 물가가이 계속 올라가면
지금 유럽도 올렸고 일본도 올렸고
한국도 올릴 거고 그래서 이게 지금
마이크론의 실적보다도이
물가가
올라간 [콧방귀] 부분에 대해서
중앙은행이 지금 긴축으로 들어가는
거거든요. 긴축으로 그러면 패드도
올릴 거예요. 제가 말씀드리 올릴
건데 7월 29일 날 올려도
괜찮아요. 올려도 괜찮은데 8월하고
9월로 넘어가면 7월에는 6월
CPI가 발표되잖아요.
>> 예.
>> 근데 6월은 지금 미국 월드컵 경기
어제 보니까 하이라이트에서 알젤리랑
요르단이랑 붙는데도 샌프란시스코의
경기장에 관중이 꽉찼더라고. 어 뭐
인기 국가도 아닌데 꽉찼더라고요.
어 그런 걸 보면서 아 6월 달
월드급 기간 동안에는 일단 보용도
탄탄하고 물가도 안 떨어지겠구나 그런
생각이 들었고요. 그러면 7월에
발표하는 6월 물가 우리가 아 이게
금리를 안 올려도 될 만한 숫자는 안
나올 거예요. 근데 8월에 발표되는
7월의 물가는 약간 이제
월드컵이 끝났으니까. 네. 그리고
9월에 발표하는 8월의 CPI는
어 아 이게 꺾이는게 아 꺾이는
거네. 고용도 꺾이고 그런 모습이
보이면서 오히려 이번에는 9월 10월
보통 조정이 좀 월드컵이랑이 CPI
숫자 때문에 좀 빨리 왔다는 느낌
받거든요. 원래는 9월 10월 요때
이제 조정을 많이 받잖아요. 예예.
그래서 한두 달 조정해 좀 빨리 오고
오히려 9월 10월 되면
>> 어 CPI가 확실하게 꺾이는 모습
그다음에 고용이 악화되는 모습네
그러면서 아예 금리 못 올려 못 올려
해서 어 9월 16일까지 두 번
올려도 돼요. 봤을 때는 두 번
올려도 되는데 더 이상은 이제 못
올려. 더 이상은 못 올려라는게
투자자들한테 조금 자신감을 주면서
그때부터 랠리가 또 다시 시작됐다.
어, 저는 이제 그런 생각을 하고
있습니다.
>> 그래서 이번 한 두 세 달이 이번에
참 상대적으로 소해되신 분들 예.
주식을 못 사서 많이 소해감을
느끼시는 분들이 꽤 많거든요.
>> 그런 분들이 좋은 주식을 싸게 살 수
있다. 아주 좋은 계절. 그리고
삼성전자 하이닉스의 시총이
보여주셨듯이 그 4,000조를 만들어
버렸잖아요.
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 그래서이 4천조 큰 형님이 이만큼
당겨 주니까
나중에 중세홍주 동생들도 결국은
따라온다 했잖아요. 동생들도 따라올
건데 금리가 인상되는 국면에서 못
따라오죠. 그렇죠. 그래서이 금리가
아요 정도에서 이제 끝났어. 그걸
갖다가 정확하게 누가 가르쳐 주냐면
심령물 북제가 가르쳐 준 거라는
거죠. 9월 달 되면 9월에서
10월로 넘어가면서는 신용물 국채
금리가 4.2, 4.0, 3.8 툭툭
떨어지면서 네. 그러면서 아 이제
동생들도 따라와도 돼라는 시그널을
준다고 그렇게 생각합니다. 그래서요
3개월 동안에는 그냥 내가 알주식만
하고 있는 분들은 아예 계좌 덮어
놓고 3개월 동안 어 여행이나 실컷
놀다 오셔도 돼요. 그냥 3개월 동안
덮어 놓고. 근데 주식이 없으시거나
이런 분들은 저희 채슬리 TV를 예.
마침바 보시면서 어 그 타이밍을 잘
노려 보시면 될 거 같은데 7월
말에서 한 8월
정도가 진입 시점이 되지 않을까 그런
생각을 합니다. 자 그러면 어 국내
시장으로 넘어가 보도록 하겠습니다.네
전일 시작 말씀드리겠습니다.
호스피 10% 가까이 급락이
나왔었고요. 호스닥이 한 8% 가량
큰폭의 하락률을 기록을 했습니다.
봐 주시면 개인 투사자가 8조
5,억대 현물 수매수를 하면서 외인과
기관의 매도를 전부 받아내는 모습이
나타났고요. 외국인이 4조 때 그리고
기관에서는 한 4조 5,억 정도
매도가 많이 나왔습니다. 선물
쪽에서는 외국인이 장 중에는 계속
매도로 봤었는데 장 끝나고 나서 좀
매수 전환하는 모습이 나타났던 거
같습니다.
투자자별 외 동향 보면 외국인 투자는
LG 이노텍을 매수를 했었고요. 그
외에는 미래셋, 삼성전기, 현대
모비스, HD, 현대중업, 부산 등을
매수를 했습니다. 외국인 매도에는
SK하이닉스 2조 6,억 가량 매도가
나왔고요. 그리고 SK 스퀘어 1조
1천억대 매도 있었습니다. 그 외에는
현대차, 삼성전자 우선주, 삼성 물산
등을 매도를 했었고요. 기관 매수에는
어 DB 하이텍 삼양식품 한국항공
우주 심택 효성 중공업 등을 매수를
했고 매도에는 SK이닉스 삼성전자
어이 두 종목을 한 3조 8천억 정도
3조 9천억 정도 매도하는 모습이
나타났습니다. 그 외에는 ETF
종목들이었고요.
52주 신고가 종목이 확
줄어들었습니다. 다섯 종목인데
시가총에 다 작은 업 종목들이고 뭐
코스피에서선 보해 양쪽 부급 철강
보스닥에선 JW 신약 등이 어
신고하기를 어렸습니다.
그 국민연금은 주식을 팔아야 돼요?
지금
팔아야 [목을 가다듬음] 된다는
이야기가 좀 있는 거 같은데
>> 정확히 정해지지 않습니다.
>> 실제 팔기 시작한 거예요? 아니면
기사에서는 일부 팔았다라고는
나오고요. 어, 그리고 7월부터 이제
본격적으로 이제 더 팔 거다라는
얘기가 있습니다.
>> 아, 7월부터 지금 1.5조원 정도
이번 달 들어서 매도하기 시작을 했고
그리고 7월 중순까지 계속 매도를
해야 됩니다. 아마 하루에 한 3,
4,억 정도 매도를 계속 취속할
겁니다.
>> 네. 그런 또 수급적인 부분이 있다
보니까 그죠. 어 최근에 외국인이
어제 거저게 잠깐만 어제
6조 정도 매도한 걸로 받는데 여기는
4조 1600억 정도로 나오네요.음
음.
>> 근데 그 아마 전 끝나고 나서 더
배이
11조 정도 내서 걸 신차 분석하다
보니까
넘어서는 이제 좀 그렇게 나왔었는데
그러니까 지금 주체가 보면 그나마
위로 쳐올리면서 사는 주체가
외국인이나 기관인데 외국인하고
국민연에서 또 매도가 나오다 보니까
그러니까 외국인 기관 다 매도세가
나오는 는 와중에 어 시장에 좀 조정
원인이 발생하니까 쉽게 좀 빠지는
모습이고 여기서 또 외국인 어제도
보면 어 하이닉스 두 배짜리는 사면서
어제 하이닉스는
매도하는 모습이 그저께 나왔었잖아
그죠 그런 걸 보면서 [콧방귀]
CFT 계좌 국내 CFT 계좌를
이용하는 어 국내
>> 검은 머리일 가능성이 높다.
그렇게 좀 출력을 했는데 말씀드린
대로이 [콧방귀] 레브리지 투자가 어
너무 많하셨어요. 신용 장구도 한
지금 37조 정도 되잖.
>> 그렇습니다. 예.
그런 모습이고 그래서 수급적으로도
일단 어 국민연금의 매도가 또 나오고
있거든요. 알겠습니다.
자 52조 신고가 볼까요? 어 다섯
종목밖에 안 되네.
>> 어 말씀드렸습니다.
>> 어 코스닥 세 종목 그다음에 코스피
종목
나 시총이 2,억도 안 되는게
없다.네
>> 크
>> 어제 코스피 200 종목 중에서도
옳은 종목이 다섯 종목밖에 안 되.
>> 네네.
>> 초토와 돼서 네. 자 주요 종목들
동량 한번 보겠습니다.
>> 네. 반도체 섹터 봐 주시면 어제
대형 반도체에 뭐 급락하는 모습이
나왔었고요. 뭐 특별한 이슈가 있어서
빠졌던 거 같진 않습니다. 그냥
MSCI
선진국 지수 편입이 좀 불발이 되었다
뭐 이런 이야기가 좀 있었고 또
어 민주당 쪽에서
주식
이실현 손익에 대한 세금을 거둬야
된다. 부동산도 그렇고 그런 이야기도
오전장에 좀 있었던 거 같고요.
MSI 불발되면서 또 아까 말씀해주신
국민연금 매도가 한 50조 정도
나와야 되는 걸 알고 있는데 MSI
선지북 지수 편의 때문에 한 40조
정도의 수급 효과를 기대할 수
있다라고 했었잖아요. 그래서 받아갈
수 있는 수급이 더 사라진게 아니냐
그런 [콧방귀]
노이즈가 시장에 좀 작용을 했던 거
같고 대형 반도체 쪽은 전자에닉스 한
12%씩
크게 하락세를 보였었고요. 아래
소부장 종목들도 뭐 대체로 10%
이상 낙폭을 보였던 종목이 상당히
많이 나왔습니다. IT 섹터에선 삼성
전기 10% 급락이 나왔고 LG
전자나 LG 이노텍 등의 종목들도
급락했습니다. 플랫폼 섹터도 대체로
한 6에서 8% 정도 큰 낙폭을
보였었고요. 이케이 지수 3.5%
정도 하락 마감했습니다. 토크
일렉트론 6% 무라타 10% 이비된
디스코 어드반등 어 여기도 반도체
IT 섹터가 많이 하락하는
모습이었고요. 자동차 섹터에서 현대차
12% 급락이 나왔고 뭐 기아나
보비스 오토에버 등의 종목들 대출로
급락했던 거 같습니다. 그래서 로봇
관련주들도 최근에 흐름이 굉장히 안
좋고요. 확실히 FMC 이후에 더
이런 흐름이 가속화되는 느낌이고
소비제 섹터 안 좋았습니다. 뭐
그래도 시장 대비로는 나쁘지 않았는데
대형 화장품 쪽이 한 2에서 4%
정도의 낙폭을 보였고 피온용 기기도
한 4% 정도의 낙폭을 보였습니다.
아래 음식료 섹터는 약간 방어주
성격이 있다 보니까 삼양식품이 보합
정도 수준으로 마감을 했고요. 아래
KTNG도 뭐 크게 하락하진
않았습니다. 최근에 많이 올랐던
백화점 체인도 낙폭을 좀 보였는데
신세기 6% 그리고 현대 백화점 2%
정도의 하락금을 기록했습니다. 조선
철감미 기타 섹터 봐 주시면
조선주들도 특별한 이슈 없이 크게
하락하는 모습이었고요. 현중 하나
오션 7% 10%씩 각각 빠졌고
아래 철강이나 화학 섹터도 큰
포기하라는 있습니다. 그리고 방산도
한 4%대의 약세흐름을 보여줬고요.
바이오섹터도 코스닥 안 좋다 보니
코스닥 바이오주들
대체로 약세로 마감을 하는 모습이었고
장중에 좀 플러스를 기록하는 모습들도
나왔는데 막판 들어가면서 더 시장이
빠지다 보니
>> 코스닥 바이오도 같이 무너지는 흐름이
나왔습니다.
그리고 은행주나 증권주 대체로 약세
흐름을
보였고요.
증권주에 대한 최근에 숏 리포트들도
일부 좀 있더라고요. 뭐 실적이야 뭐
이런 건 다 괜찮지만 거래대금이 어느
정도 픽아웃된게 아니냐 그러면서 주가
상방이 다칠 수 있다. 이런 산업
리포트들이 최근에 좀 나왔던 거
같습니다. 멘토 쪽은 하이브를
비롯해서 대체로 다 크게 하락했고요.
변학기 쪽도 큰 납폭을 보였습니다.
과거의 패턴으로 보면 시장이 좀
약세장으로 갈 수 있다라고 하면
거래대금이 확실히 줄어들 거니까
그러면 브로크리지
영업이 주였던 정권사의 수익이
줄어들고 그러면서 정권주가 빠지는 그
패턴이 반복됐었는데
사실 최근에 정권주가 엄청
강했었잖아요. 그죠? 그리고
최근권주들이
고점 대비 이제 30% 막 이렇게
빠지는 주식들이 나오거든요. 나오는데
지금 증권사 저희가 증권사랑 많은 어
밀접하게 랩도 하고 이것저것 많이
하기 때문에이 증권사가 어떻게 지금
영업을 하고 어디서 돈을 버는지
저희도 또 되게 잘 아는데 언제부턴가
예전에 피가로 피가로 하면서 하나
정권에서 어
매매 수료가 났다. 어디서는 매매수
평생 무료 아니 매매 브로크
브로크리지 하우스인데 그 브로크리지
피를 안 받고 어떻게 영험을 하지?
돈을 자금을 모아놓고 거기서 신용으로
신용 이자도 벌고 금융 상품 팔고
이러면서 실제 금융 상품 영업으로
많이 바뀌었어요. 그죠?
그렇기 때문에 실제 거래대금도 물론
중요하긴 한데 시장이 좋아야 유입되는
어 고객대수가 많아지니까 자금도
많아지고 근데 지금은이
배세 상승 추세 크게 우리나라의 금융
자산이 부동산으로 너무 많이가
있었던게 지금 금융으로 오고 있고
금융에서도 은행에가 있던 자금이 지금
정권으로 넘어거죠.이
이 사실은 구조적 성장에 들어가 있는
산업이라고 빠지기 때문에 과거의
패턴으로만 생각하고 주가가 빠진다.
사실 그냥
오과장이 [콧방귀] 그랬지 파라바 사
줄게.
>> 어 BMP 파라바 사 줄게.
뭐 그런 느낌으로 사실 사면 돼요.
근데 당장 지금 당장 지금 사서 오
일주일 동안 아니면 한 달 보고
들어가는 분들은 좀 어렵겠지만 지금
가격이 이제 착해져 있어요. 봤을 때
직권주 보면은 사실은 지금 미국이나
[목을 가다듬음] 우리나라나
상승의
질 자체가 뭐 좀 이걸 뭐 같이
판단하기는 그렇지만 그렇게 좋은 건
아니잖아요. 증권주가 되려면 사실
개인 투자자들분들이 좋아하시는 중세
음주나 아 코스닥이나 이쪽이 어떤
테마를 형성하면서 매매가 활발하게
일어나야 되는데 요즘 그런게 별로
없다고 하더라고요. 한번 물려 있으면
또 잘 팔지 못하고 리밸런싱 하기가
어려운게 좀 개인 투자자분들의
현실이다 보니까 그리고 삼성전자
하이닉스 위주로 대형주 위주로만
움직이다 보니까 거래대금 자체는
많지만 개인 투자자분들이 거래하는
그런 거래 빈도의 횟수나 그런 환경
자체는 이전의 상승장만 못하다는 그런
평가들도 좀 있습니다.
>> 그러게.
그리고 어제도 어 워맨 신박 신문에서
다루려다가 빼기 냈었는데 지금 두
개짜리 레블이지 이런 것 때문에
증권사만 돈 번다. 어 그런 얘기도
있거든요. 여러 가지 환경으로 보면
뭐 미국 주식 뭐 최근에 조정 때문에
뭐 미국 주식 안 할 거예요. 미국
주식 하는 분들은 계속 늘어날 거
아니에 그것습니다.
국내 주식, 미국 주식이
밸런스 있게 가져가려고 하는 분들을
많다 보니까 그게 증권사 같은
경우에는 뭐 앞으로도 하여튼 빠지면
제일
그 100년이 지나도 살아 있을
회사는 증권사라고 생각을 그죠.
100년이 지나도 제조 업체인는 뭐
어떻게 될지 모르겠는데 100년이
지나도 뭐 미국의 블랙 이런 것도
100년이 지나도 살아 있을 거고
[콧방귀]
그런 개념으로 어 내가 어떤 주식을
사는가 어떤 가치가 있고 거기서 가치
대비 내가 얼마나 좋은 가격에 사는가
예 그런 관점으로 좀 바라보시면
주가가 빠진다는 거를 절대 나쁜 건
아닙니다. [콧방귀] 자, 그러면
리포트를 볼 건데 유한타 이재원
연구원이 매일 무한정 오르는 주식은
없다. 어, 재밌는 제목이 네. 어제
장이 급락하면서 장중에 나왔던
리포트였는데요.
코스피 코스닥이 급락을 했고 양지수
메도사이드 카가 발동을 했었다.
그리고 코스피 서킷 것까지
걸렸었었는데요.이 아시아 주식 시장
내에서도 한국에만 국한된
상황이었다라고 하는데 양환 흐름의
아시아 주식 시장에서 확인할 수
있듯이 매크로 지표 변동성도
양이었다. 그래서이 리포트가 나왔을
때만 해도 니케가 한 1%대
조정이었거든요. 이제 리케이지수도
막판들어서 한 3% 이상으로 마감하긴
했었는데 뭐 한국 시장이 상대적으로
많이 빠지긴 했던 거 같습니다. 시장
금리나 유가급 등량은 장중에 없었고
조정의 원인은 반도체 대형주 차익
실현 매물 출회 및 기술적 조정
정도로 보고 있다. 하이닉스 팔거릴
연속 상승하면서 신고가 랠리가
이어졌었고 이평선과의 개리율이
커졌었는데
또한 76.2로 과매수 구간에 진입을
했었고 언제든지 기술적 조정이
가능하나 추세적는 아니라는 판단이라고
합니다. 현재 펀더멘탈과 매크로에서
코스피 상승 추세를 훼손할 만한
문제까지는 발견되지 않았었다라고 하고
5,000포인트나 6천 7천
8,000포인트 돌파 이후 있어 왔던
차익실험 매물 출애 과정으로 해석이
가능하다라고 하고요. 저가 매수
회계로 활용할 필요가 있겠다. 물론
PC의 경계감이나 마이크론 실적
경계감, 어, BOA의 연내 금리
3회 인상 전반등 후행적 명분을 어,
붙일 수는 있겠지만 이것이 금일
아시아에서 한국만 유일하게 급락하는
이유가 되기는 좀 어렵다라고 보고요.
결론은 많이 올랐기 때문에 많이
빠지는 것이라고 볼 수가 있겠고
9,피 돌파 이후 나타나야 할 통과
의뢰에 가깝다. 26년 코스피
100% 이상 상승하면서
4,000에서 9,000포인트까지
지수 1000포인트당 단위 최초 돌파
이후 평균 6거래일 이내에 5%
이상의 1일 낙폭이 꾸준히
발생했었다라고 하고요. 평균 낙폭은
6% 수준이었다라고 합니다. 어제
조정 역시 해당 범준의 계수적
조정으로 판단을 하고 추세 훼손보다는
과연 해소 성격이 좀 더 강하지
않을까 이야기를 했습니다. 뭐
1,000포인트 오를 때마다 저는 제
기억으로 5,000에서 5,300
처음에 5,000 포인트 뚫으면
5,3400까지 갔다가 한번 쭉
빠지고 그다음에 이제 다시 펑 튀면서
5, 후반 갔다가 또 조금 며칠
조정받고 6천 뛰어넘고 6,300
갔다가 또 6,까지 받았다가 이런
모습이 계속 있었는데 이번에도 그거랑
마찬가지라는 거죠. 봤을 때는 저
아래 차트 코스피 차트를 튀어나왔는데
[목을 가다듬음]
흐름이 뭐 항상 비슷한 거 같습니다.
저 5월 달부터의 흐름이 거의
비슷하죠. 그 상승의 길이도 비슷하고
하락의 길이도 비슷하거든요. 그래서
근데 이번에는 조금 달랐던 거는 하루
만에 좀 세게 패다
>> 느낌이 있는 거 같아요. 그래서
확실히이
>> 지수 상승률이
연초 대비 올랐기 때문에 조정이 나올
때도 더 깊게 나오고 올라가는 또
올라갈 때 또 길 크게 나온 생각이
듭니다. 그래서 이번에도 여기서 한
방에 뭐 반등해서 다시 9천을
가기보단 조금 아래에서 흔들다가 갈
가능성이 높지 않을까 그런 생각이 좀
듭니다.
지난번처럼 요렇게 이격이 130 딱
넘어가서 조정받으면 좋은데
>> 어 이번에는 곳까지 가기 전에 확 빼
버렸다 그죠?
그리고 마이크로 실적 발표도 그렇고
최근에 드는 생각이 과거 패턴으로는
아 요럴 때 요렇게 오르고 그다음에
빠지니까 내가 요때 들어가서 요거
직전에 팔아먹어야지 하면 어 너
그렇게 생각하고 있지 나는 한 수 더
빨리 줄 거야 하면서 시장이 그죠
>> 어 과거 패턴보다 확실하게
빨라졌어요. 보니까
>> 그게 그런 퀀터 분석이나 이런게
사실은 소수의 사람들만이 분석을 해서
하는 전략이었다면
요즘은 뭐 강한국 작가도 얘기하고
저도 얘기하고 하다 보니까 조금 이제
순발력이 있는 사람들이 아 그래
그러면 나는 하루 더 빨리 내려야지
약간 그렇게 바뀌어요.
>> 뭐 AI 영향도 있지 않을까?
>> AI 뭐든지 다 알 수 있어요.
>> 네. AI 물어보면 다 가르쳐주.
>> 다 알려줬죠.
그래서 확실히
>> 자체가 없어졌습니다.
정보의
>> 팔런티나 뭐 정보의 양 자체가 예전에
말씀하신 분들 소스나 한정된 사람들에
안에서 사용될 수 있다면 지금은 뭐
모두한테 다 오픈돼 있는데 그 영향이
어 AI 때문
>> 맞습니다. 우리 보너 배트님 말씀대로
사람들이 똑똑해지고 AI 되 때문에
수싸움이 치열해지는데
>> 어 세 수,네 수 그러면 나는 다섯
수 빨리 먼저 그런 현상이 보여지고
있습니다. 아무튼 제가 그이 최근의
조정을 스콜에 비교했잖아요.
우리나라도 봄 가을이 좀 없어지고
빨리 더워지면서 어 스콜성
소나귀 같은 게
>> 자주 오듯이 우리나라 정시도 마찬가지
엄청 뜨거운 시장이 됐잖아요.
>> 그게 뜨겁기 때문에 과열도 빨리 되고
그러면 그 과일을 시키는 이런 조정도
확실히 옛날 정도 이렇게 진폭이
확실히 달라졌어요.
>> 그렇습니다.
그렇게 스콜이라 생각하시고요. 음.
자, 그다음에 어, 이연택 연구원
자료도 나왔네요. 역사가 말하는
주도주 솔립 마지막회 주도주 붕괴의
순서 이연택 연구 자료도 보겠습니다.
시간이 많이 지나서 좀 빠르게
말씀드리면 뭐 지금까지 뭐 1편도
있었고 2편도 있었고 한데 뭐 마지막
해라고는 합니다. 어 이번 내용은
20년 하반기 전망 업종 전략 부분을
발치한 건데 자세한 내용은 하반기
전망 자료고 가능하다라고 리포트 그
싸움 리포트 보면 길게 쓰신 거
있거든요. 거기 보면 정리된게 잘
나오고 이번엔 주도주 솔립 시리즈의
마지막 편으로 다컴버을 말기
주도주들이 무너져 내리던 과정을
통해서 현재 시장해 줄 수 있는
시사점을 좀 살펴보고자라고
했습니다. 2000년 4월부터
나스닥의 본격적인 붕괴가 먼저
왔었다라고 하는데요. 처음에는 당시
닷컴 관련 주식들도 4월을 기점으로
일제에 급락했을 것이라 생각했지만
실제 데이터를 보면 하락에도 순서가
있었다라고 합니다. 분계는 가장 먼
미래를 당겨온 주식들부터 시작됐다라고
하는데 인터넷 서비스와 무선통신 관련
기업들이 뭐 퀄컴이나 AOL, 야후
등이 대표적 사례였다라고 하고요.
이들은 나스닥의 고점을 기록하기도
2000년 1월부터 이미 급락을 하기
시작했었다라고 합니다. 그다음 2차
분기는 과도한 케펙스 기대가 반영된
인프라 관련 종목들에서 나타났었다라고
하는데요.컴 버블 당시에는 단순히
닷컴 사업을 시작한다는 소문만으로
주가가 급등하는 현상이 있었다라고
하고 대표적으로 한국에선 새로운
기술이 있었고 무료 인터넷 전화
서비스인 다이얼패드 기대감만으로 상장
이후 100배 이상 급등을 했었다라고
합니다. 그래서 지금 구간에서는
어 그 관련주로는 로봇 쪽을 좀
이연택 연구 얘기를 하는 거 같고요.
그래서 뭐 이미 좀 먼저 빠지기
시작했죠. 현대 차도 지금 거의
80만 원 갔다 50만 원
됐으니까요. 순식간에 빠졌었고 그리고
최근에 뭐 젠슨 와서 올랐었던 LG
CNS라든지
뭐 삼성 SDS 그리고 네이버도 사실
젠슨이랑 조금 엮기면서 한번
급등했다가 바로 내려오는 모습이었는데
뭐 이런 종목들은
[목을 가다듬음]
순식간에 먼저 빠지는 경우가
있었다라는 이야기를 했고 그리고
마지막 생존자는 실적으로 증명된
기업들이었다라고 하는데요. 금리가
상승하고 랠리가 후반으로 갈수록 가장
먼저 경계할 대상은 이익이 부족하고
손익분기점이 먼 미래에 있는
기업들이라고 볼 수가 있다라고
합니다. 현재 시장에서 일부 전력이나
로봇 우주 관련 테마수들이 이에
해당한다라고 볼 수가 있겠고요. 반면
반도체 업종은 실적 견적 구조 공급
부족이라는 가격 강력한 투자 논리를
보유하고 있어서 어 상대적으로 더
오랜 기간 시장의 주도 주지위를
유지할 가능성이 있다라는
이야기했습니다.
그래서 흥미로운 점은 현재 투자자들의
심리 역시 30년 전선 전과 크게
다르지 않다라는 거고요. 실제로 5월
중순 삼성전자 파업 이슈 등으로
시장이 흔들렸을 당시 전자보다 로봇
우주 관련 테마주들의 주가 변동성이
더 크게 나타었다.이는 투자자들이
이미 많이 오른 반도체보다 실적이
부족한 테마주에 대해 더 큰 불안감을
느끼고 있음을 실한다라고 하고요.
결국 주가 부담이 존재하더라도
실적으로 증명되고 있는 기업들이
마지막까지 살아남이 높고 현재
시장에서는 여전히 반도체가 그 유력한
후보다라고
이야기를 했습니다.
[목을 가다듬음]
어 상당히어 재미난 리포터이고이 다컴
붕괴가 4월부터 시작은 됐지만 미리
야우 같은게 1월 달부터 빠졌단
말이죠.
아메리칸 온라인도 그랬고 그랬네요.
99년 12월에 고점치고 빠졌고
ї컴도 1월 달에 먼저 조정이 먼저
있었었고 근데 요때도 마찬가지지만
이때 2000년도에도
금리를 계속 올리던 시기였어요.
2000년에 왜 금리를 계속 올렸냐면
2000년 4월 뭐 이럴 때도 보면
어 실험률이 계속 낮게 유지까지
됐었거든요. 예. 4월에도 실험률이
3 3.8이다 보니까 패드 입장에서는
아예 고용이 탄탄하기 때문에 금리를
올려도 돼 하면서 그러면서 6.5까지
올리게 되는데 그 와중에 어 제가
지난주에도 어 비율를 목욕탕으로
말씀을 드렸었는데이
38° 39° 40도 41도는
괜찮다는 거죠. 근데 43도만 돼도
애들은 못 들어가 있어요. 애들은
그죠? 피부가 연약한 애들은 뭐 벌떡
뛰어나오게 되죠. 44, 45 되면
진짜 뜨거워지는 건데 그러면 다 뛰쳐
나오게 되는데 체력이 약하고 실적이
안 되고 미래 뭘 하겠다. 근데
지금은 당장 돈 당겨서 투자를 해야
되는 그런 스토리주들이
박살나게 돼 있다는 거죠.
그래서 2000년도에도
어 금리를 계속 올리다가 그게
5.5에서 6 넘어가고 뭐 그러는
와중에 종목들이 이렇게 부러지게
됩니다. 뿌려지게 되고 결국은 시장이
박살나고 나서 뒤늦게 했어야
2000년 12월인가
2001년부터
금리를 낮추기 시작하는데 이미 주가가
많이 빠지고 망하는 기업들이 그때부터
조금 조금씩 이제 나오기 시작
그러면서 와장창 망하다 보니까
실험률이 쫙 올라오게 6%가 넘어가는
그런 모습이 나왔습니다.
그런 얘기를 어 해 줬었는데 일단
때랑 지금하고는 좀 많이 달라요.이
스토리 주식은 여기서는 뭐 로봇이나
우주 요것도 해당되지만 제가 제일
걱정하는 거는 알트코인 저쪽 코인
시장 저 봤을 때는 코인 시장이 어
엄청난 구조 조정이 지금 일어나고
있고요.
그다음에 뭐 종목별로나 스토리 주식
빠지는 모습 나올 거고
지금 실적 기반으로 올라오는
AI 관련주들 예 그런 주들은
>> 어 금리에 얼마나 이렇게 또 견딜 수
있었을까 생각해 보면
견딜 수가 있죠.
실적을 내고 이미 어 숫자가 나오는
기업들이
기업
감사합니다. 어 시간이 많이 지났는데
어 댓글창을 보면서 제가 하나 드는
생각은요.이
선수들한테는 이런 조정장이이
종목 리밸런싱의 기회가 되거든요.
리밸런싱이 기가 되는데 어이
빠질 때 보면 리밸런싱을 잘 못
하십니다. 오히려 반대로 하시는
경우가 많아요. 어 좀 덜 빠진 거
아 이거라도 좀 팔아놔야지.
그래서 정작극
사야 될 주식을 팔아 버리고
>> 팔아야 될 주식을
만 더 갖고 있고
>> 예 굉장히 중요한
>> 예 그래서 어 지금 많이 물려 있는데
이거 어떻게 해야 되나요? 뭐 이런
분들도 많으시는데 어 솔직히 그
주식들 싹다 팔아서 저희 랩으로
옮기는 것도 저는 방법이라고
생각했습니다.
>> 그거는 뭐 잘 판단하셔서 하면 뵙긴
한데
그게 모든 스포츠가 다 그렇죠.
미기가 왔을 때 프로들은 그걸 잘
극복해. 트러블 슈팅이라고 하는데 잘
극복해서 나오고
오히려
좀 초보자분들은
더 내 자신의 포지션을 더 어렵게
만들죠.
그래서 이번 위기처럼 보이는 이번 초
정도 이해가 될 거라 말씀드리고 자
시장했는데 그래도 어 야간 선물이 한
1% 정도였는데 우리 시장은 그래도
강하게 시작했네. 네.
>> 네. 시초가 1.8% 시작했고요.
현재는 3.4%까지 상승폭 확대를
하고 있습니다.
>> 네.
코스닥은 어떻게 됩니까?
>> 네. 코스닥은 1.5%. 어 시작을
해서 상승 출발했고요. 현재는
1.1%까지 소폭 어 하락을 하고
있습니다.
다행이 어제 급락의 반발 매수가 계속
나오고 있습니다.
자 미국 시장
어떻게 될 거 같데
다 하락했었을 겁니다. SP 500
나스닥은 하락갔다라고.
>> 아, 하락했어요. 어, 맞네. 맞는
>> 네. 일반은 플러스라고 했고
>> 유리프로가 마이너스 하락할 거라고
예상했던 이유는 뭐였었죠?
이제
갑자기 물어보니까 기억이 안 나긴
하는데. 음.
일단 너무 과열됐다라는게 어제 주요
이유였다라고 생각을 하고요. 그래서
아마 말씀드릴 때도
어 [콧방귀]
나스닥이 더 큰 폭으로 계속 하락할
거다라고 말씀드렸던 거 같습니다.
확복이라고는 얘기 안 했고 어 조정이
하루 정도는 더 이어질 것 같다.
네.
>> 그런 얘기네.
>> 오늘은 어떻게 됩니까? [콧방귀]
>> 음.
오늘도 사실
[콧방귀] 조금 오르고 있긴 한데요.
선물 기준으로는. 근데 계속 말씀
주셨듯이 빅스 지수가 아직은 좀 높은
수준이라서
오늘 마이크로 실적 봐야 이제
알겠지만은 그래도 소승하지 않을까
지수 모두 생각합니다.
>> 사실 미리 빠졌으니까 또
>> 예.
오히려
SMP 500 나스다 모두 오늘은
플러스 전환할 거다.
>> 필반은 어떻게 된 거?
>> 상승.
>> 어 필반
>> 하루 소나이었다.
>> 예. 하루 순나이었다라고 생각합니다.
예 그리고 오히려 좀 좋은
조정이었다. 없는 사람들한테는.
그리고 있는 사람들한테 좀 아프긴
하지만
저는 계속해서 그 전고점을
그 저기 상해하는 그런
방향이 나올 거로 생각을 하고
있거든요. 그래서 그냥 버티면
된다라고 생각을 합니다. 그래서 오늘
상승으로 생각을 하고 내일도 아마
마이콘 수쇼 뭐 무난이 잘 나올 거로
생각을 하고 이미 좀 빠져 있기
때문에
약간 실적에 대한 부담을 조금 덜지
않았을까 그런 생각도 들고 이제 내일
톤이나 숫자들 봐야 되겠지만 저는
정황상으로 어 굉장히 톤도 셀 거
같고요. 숫자도 셀 거 같습니다.
왜냐면 계속해서 나오는 어 캠팩스에
대한 확대 그리고 또 가격에 대한
상향 조정 이런 것들을 감안했을 때
긍정적으로 보고 있습니다.
[목을 가다듬음]
자, 그다음에 어 국내 시장
보겠습니다. 국내 시장 어제 코스피
네. 오가 어제 양봉 예상했었는데 와
>> 네. 어제
근데 우리 시랑 좀 앞으로 계속
일으려나? 어 좀 걱정도 돼요. 자.
그럴 거 같아.
>> 반도체 두 개가 너무 시총이 커져
가지고.
아니, 근데 뭐 반도체만 반도체
빠지면서 다른 것들이 쫙 올라가서
모르겠지만
반도체 투탁도 빠지면서 뭐 다른
것들도 뭐 다 투매식 그런 아름답이
나와 가지고
오늘은 어떻게 될 거 볼린저 밴드로
보면 어떻게 되
>> 아 볼린저 밴드는 이미 말씀드렸다시피
지난주 금요일에 딱 상단 터체하고
내려왔었거든요. 그래서 이번 주는 좀
약할 것 같다. 데 주초는 세고 후방
가면
>> 반등 나올 것 같다라고 했는데 주초에
일단 세게 하데 맞아 버려 가지고
오늘부터는
근데 이게 한 방에 또 바로 가는
경우는 없어 가지고 좀 밑에서 흔들
거 같긴 한데 오늘은 일단 양봉 오늘
세게 너무 세게 가면 내일 마이크로
실적 잘 나와도 운동 날산어
생각이라 오늘 일단 양봉해
보겠습니다. 오늘 양고
양고 코스닥은 어떻게 나오죠? 제
음봉이라고 얘기했었는데 음봉이었다.
그죠?
>> 네. 네. 오늘도 음봉.
>> 오늘도 음봉이에요.
>> 보통 어제처럼 장대 음봉이
나오잖아요.
>> 네. 그러면 내가 옛날에 선물 매매할
때는 어 요런 날이 좀 쉬운 날인데
많이 빠졌기 때문에 반발 매수가
처음에 들어오게 돼요. 처음에
들어오는데 그 뭐 쇼케팅은 하지 않기
때문에 예 돈을 하지 않지만 전에 그
절대 수입 펀드 백수 리턴 펀드 하는
AR ARF 같은 거 그런 거는 이제
해치를 해야 되기 때문에 해치를 해야
되는데 어제처럼 장대 연봉이 나오면
그 장대 연봉의 중간값은이
돌파를 강하게 하는 장악형 양봉이 잘
안 나와요.
>> 음.
>> 장학형 양봉은 열 번 중에 한 번
정도 나오려나? 확률적으로는 그
중간값을 회복 못 하고 빠지죠.
왜냐면 어제 개인들 매수가 11조가
있었었거든요. 떨어지면 사는 사람들은
또 올라가면 아 오늘 팔아먹어야지
하고 들어와서 위에다가 걸어 놓게
되고 그다음에 현금 하나도 없이
떨어진 사람들은 아 올라오면 좀
줄여야 되겠네. 그러면서 위에 걸어
놓고 그 아까 수금 얘기했었지만
국민연금이 만약 계속 팔아야 된다면
오늘도 뭐 매도가 나올 수가 있고
외국인 같은 경우에는 아까 뭐
금리라든지
페드의 금리 인사 요런 걸 좀 보고
단기적으로
그 외국인 얘기하니까 외국인은 옵션
포지션이 최근에 어떤 포지션이냐면
좀 이해가 안 되는 포지션인데
양매수를
잡고 있더라고 음.
>> 근데 양매수 잡아서 주가가 왔다 갔다
하면서 그냥 9천에서
1,500억 손실 포지션이었거든.
>> 음.
>> 아, [콧방귀] 이렇게 양매수를 잡는
거는 처음 봤었어요. 그 양매수는
오히려 숏마당 반대 개념 예.
변동성이 커질 거에 대한 배팅을 하는
건데 그래서 7,900이
깨져야 이익이 화나는데 예. 그런
포지션을 잡는다고. 그리고 반대로
위로도 마찬가지예요. 위로도
>> 9,500 이상 돌파하면 또 이익이
나요.
>> 음.
>> 그래서 야, 외국인이 보통은 개인들이
이렇게 양매수 많이 잡는데 외국인이
지금 변동성이 커서 옵션의 가격이 어
굉장히 비싸져 있거든요. 비싸져
있는데 이걸 매수를 잡는다고
그랬었는데 어제 한 방에 10% 이제
빠지게 됐어.
그래서 외국인 입장에서도
어 아직까지는
좀 더 빠지는게 외국인 안 되는
그러면이 외국인나 옵션 플레이어들은
반도체
매매 동량을 얘네들이 홍콩에서 나오는
치펀드나 이런 쪽에서 나오는 반도체
플로우를 좀 잘 알고 있던데 오늘
같은 경우는 어 [콧방귀] 30분
동안 외국인이 이 반도체에 대해서
어떤 매매를 하고 있는가요?
단체는 약간 수레요. 이제 어
삼성전자는 1,500억 정도 지금
매수를 외국인이 하고 있고요. 오늘
시장 전체적으로 봤을 때도 외국인이
크게 팔진 않고 있어요. 한
5,800억 정도. 어제 같은
시간에선 한 1주 정도 매도가
나왔었거든요.
>> 근데 벌써 5,800억. 벌써
5,800원 정도 매도를 하고
있습니다.
>> 아니 전자 물론 지금 외국인 추정은
외국의 창구만 추정입니다. 추정
맞습니다.
>> 그러면 하이닉스는
>> 하이닉스는 -4,600억 정도 지금
매도로 잡힙니다.
>> 네. 레드로죠.
그래서 오늘 근데 시초가가 약간 아까
1% 시초가가 1% 정도네 1.8%
아 1.8% 정도 나온다고
그래서 오늘 바로 어 장학형 양봉이
나오기에는 오늘은 좀 힘들 수 있다.
예 그렇게 생각을 하시고 계시는게
좋을 것 같습니다.
예 오늘 채슬린 문 브리프는 여기까지
하겠습니다. 변동성 심한장에 예,
중심이 되는 건 뭐냐면 내가 투자하고
있는 주식에 대한 밸류에이션을 하고
있으면 괜찮은데
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 예. 그게 없이 시세를 쫓면서 이제
매매하다 보니까
>> 빠지면 불안하고 올라가면 기분 좋고
뭐 그런 거 같아요.
>> 조금 그 밸루에이션에 대한 어 중심을
잡으시면서 매매하시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 네. 긴 시간 함께 해
주신 여러분 고맙습니다.